Moin Leute, ich bin heute früher als sonst, was nicht heißt, dass ich unbedingt früher abhaue, aber dass ich pünktlich abhauen kann, wenn ich Hunger kriege.
Naja, ich bin einfach schon ein bisschen früher wach gewesen heute, hab mir gedacht, bevor ich jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde sinnlos rumhocke, kann ich jetzt auch gleich schon den Stream anmachen.
Bin sozusagen der frühe Hase, wenn das jetzt ApoRed wäre.
Wie ich darauf komme, ist mir wurde lustigerweise auf YouTube gerade ein ApoRed Video empfohlen.
Und zwar, dass Dubai oder irgendwas die neue Meta ist.
Beziehungsweise ein Video von jemand, der über ein ApoRed Video redet.
Weiß nicht, ob wir uns das nachher angucken.
Ich glaube, da müssen wir echt mal durch, weil mich interessiert tatsächlich, was ApoRed so treibt.
Nach der, wie hieß das, ähm, nach dem Insi-Modus.
Können wir nachher gucken.
Leute, gab es irgendwas Spannendes die Woche, was ich verpasst habe?
Also das Einzige, an das ich mich erinnern kann, was ein bisschen größere Runden gezogen hat, ist diese Geschichte mit dem Signing-Token für Azure.
Ansonsten wüsste ich jetzt eigentlich nichts.
Kennt jemand, das suche ich schon nach einer Weile danach, kennt jemand eine gute Weekly-IT-News-Zusammenfassung?
Heise hatte früher mal was, das haben die irgendwie eingestellt.
Das muss es doch geben!
Also mir ist egal, ob in Text- oder in Videoform.
Was, die Windows-10-Taskbar?
Ja, das Problem ist, dass die Windows-10-Taskbar auch schon kacke war.
Der einzige wirkliche Vorteil, die ich sehe, der Windows-10-Taskbar ist, dass man Fenster entgruppieren konnte.
Einmal ganz davon abgesehen, selbst wenn das 15.000 Sterne hat, ich würde das nicht benutzen wollen.
Einfach weil es bei jedem neuen Update wieder kaputt gehen kann und man nicht weiß, was es genau für Auswirkungen hat aufs OS.
Also ich finde es nicht so sinnvoll, in den Tiefen von Windows rum zu patchen.
I dropped out of college.
What the fuck?
Ich finde das nicht so sinnvoll.
Ich habe mal was ähnliches gemacht, zu Zeiten von Windows 98.
Ich habe mal unter Windows 98 SE den Windows 95 Explorer reingepatcht, weil der schneller war.
Das war damals auf irgendeiner Seite oder wahrscheinlich sogar noch in irgendeiner Zeitschrift, gehe ich mal von aus.
Wahrscheinlich war das noch gar nicht im Internet.
In irgendeiner Zeitschrift habe ich das gelesen als super krassen Windows-Hack, den nicht mal Microsoft kennt.
Da habe ich dann den Windows 95 Explorer an Windows 98 probiert.
Das ging tatsächlich auch ohne jegliche Probleme, bis auf die Settings.
Der Settings-Dialog für meine Grafikkarte ging nicht mehr, weil das wohl ein neues Fenster hatte und der wurde erst im Explorer von Windows 98 unterstützt.
Pech gehabt.
Wusstest du, dass der Explorer Tabs hat?
Ja, das kenne ich.
Ich verwende die Tabs tatsächlich selten, aber das weiß ich, dass der Tabs hat, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Lass uns doch gerade mal, bevor der Stream richtig losgeht, schauen, was diese Woche so trendet auf ShitHub.
Typescript Library.
Okay, AI.
Ich überspringe immer alle AI-Geschichten.
AI, AI, AI.
China-Chinesen-AI.
AI, AI.
Ein Framework für Laravel.
Ist Laravel selbst nicht schon ein PHP-Framework?
Das ist quasi ein Framework für das Framework.
Nee, das ist Frontend.
Keine Ahnung. Interessiert mich nicht.
PHP hat mich jetzt, als ich mir das letzte Mal angeguckt habe, wirklich nicht beeindruckt mehr.
Und das ist auch gar nicht her.
Das ist erst so ein, zwei Monate her, wo wir das letzte Mal noch versucht haben, was in PHP zu machen.
Das war hochgradig eklig.
Ich habe das schon wieder komplett verdrängt.
Da waren so ein paar Basic-Sachen dabei, wo ich mir gedacht habe, das kann doch nicht sein.
Ja, zum Beispiel Loggen auf die Konsole hat nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ganz merkwürdig.
AI, AI, AI.
Salesforce, oh je.
Eine Java-VM in Rust.
Jetzt wird es abgedreht.
AI.
Python-Zeug.
AI, AI.
Keine Ahnung.
China-Chinesen-Algorithmen-Sammlung oder so.
Eine Schriftart.
Die kenne ich. Das ist eine der ersten Schriftarten, die so, ich kann mir immer nicht merken, wie das heißt,
zu mehrere Zeichen in einem unterstützt.
Ich glaube, hier, ja, das da meine ich.
Ligatures, wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Ligaturen, alles klar, ja.
Also sprich, dass beispielsweise das hier, diese zwei Zeichen, werden in dem Font zu einem Zeichen und so.
Das ist einer der ersten Fonts, die das so mit populär gemacht haben.
Gibt ja mittlerweile jede Menge andere Fonts, die das können.
PotatoBob, danke schön für den Sub.
Exzellent.
Nice.
AI.
Browser-Automatisierung.
Selenium, dass das immer noch ein Ding ist.
Und geleakte Twitter-Source-Code, ja.
Nicht sonderlich spannend, die Woche, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Trended irgendwas, guck mal, ob irgendwas in .NET interessant ist.
Trended, aber Trended meistens nichts Spannendes.
Chess, nee, nicht wirklich.
Was zum Teufel, warum Trended irgendwas?
Chess-Bot in C-Sharp.
Immerhin kein AI.
In gewisser Weise schon.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, kein AI, aber in gewisser Weise ist es ja auch AI.
Sind das Nerd-Fonts?
Nee, glaub nicht.
Nerd-Fonts sind ja normale Schriftarten gepatcht mit Unicode...
Also nein, nein, nein, das ist falsch ausgedrückt.
Nerd-Fonts sind ja normale Schriftarten gepatcht mit zusätzlichen Zeichen aus dem erweiterten quasi Unicode...
Wie nennt man das?
Spektrum.
Planes, oder wie auch immer das heißt.
Schriftarten und generell Encodings sind echt undurchsichtig.
Unicode ist ja der Standard, der festlegt, welche...
Ich glaube, Code-Points nennt sich es dort.
Welchen Zeichen entsprechen.
Allerdings legt Unicode nicht fest, wie das Zeichen am Endeffekt auszusehen hat.
Unicode legt ja auch nicht fest, wie das Emoji genau auszusehen hat.
In Unicode steht, soweit ich weiß, bloß drinnen Code-Point XY.
Ich glaube, es heißt Code-Point.
Also dieses ganze Schriftarten-Zeug ist übelst kompliziert.
Ist lachendes Emoji mit Herz.
Sowas steht da drinnen.
Wie das Ganze dann encoded wird, ist wieder eine andere Frage.
Also quasi das UTF-8, UTF-16, UTF-32, sonst was.
Und wie das Zeichen am Ende aussieht, das hängt von der Schriftart ab.
Beziehungsweise auch von der Mischung verschiedener Schriftarten.
Weil wenn eine Schriftart das Zeichen nicht kann, dann gibt es ja einen Fallback auf eine andere Schriftart.
Das heißt, man braucht ja extra noch eine Emoji-Schriftart zum Rendern von Emojis.
Das ist wirklich übelst komplizierter.
Im Endeffekt kann es sogar von Plattform zu Plattform anders aussehen.
Aber das Ding, was dann die Fonts rendert am Ende, das nochmal anders macht.
Maui. Das ist auch dead on arrival, Leute.
Ich sage euch, das wird nie Fahrt aufnehmen.
Wenn Maui nur 43 Sterne in die Woche kriegt, sagt es schon wieder aus.
Also ich gehe davon aus, Maui wird komplett...
Es ist dead on arrival.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da noch viel kommt.
Auch wenn Microsoft es immer noch versucht ein bisschen zu pushen, aber nee.
Game-Launcher für MiHo...
Was? Was ist das?
Das...
Weep-Zeug?
Ich weiß nicht, was... Ah, das ist Weep-Zeug. Okay, verstehe.
Da ist nur die Frage, ob Point Weeps in oder out.
AI?
Das ist irgendwelche VPN-Geschichten, oder?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Toilette?
Ja, nicht so spannend.
Irgendeiner meiner Mod-Kids hat das hier doch letztens verwendet.
Ich erinnere mich dunkel.
Und China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Naja, nicht so spannend.
Ist Maui sowas wie WPF?
Ja und nein.
Maui baut nicht auf der gleichen Technik wie WPF auf,
aber Maui basiert auch auf der gleichen Sprache wie man...
Also auf XAML, wie man UIs definiert.
Du wirst viele Überschneidungen zwischen Maui und WPF finden,
aber die Technik unten drunter ist was grundlegend anderes.
WPF ist eine Windows-Only-Technologie.
Es sei denn, Avalonia...
Avalonia...
...kommt mit ihrem Kram da irgendwie durch.
Die wollen ja WPF-Anwendungen Cross-Plattform machen.
Bin ich mal gespannt, wie gut das hinhaut.
Das ist ja aktuell im Internal-Preview-Beta, wie auch immer.
Da bin ich echt mal gespannt drauf, weil das könnte wir...
Wow! Gut, für Business-Enterprise-Leute weniger das Problem.
Wenn du irgendwie so eine uralte, nicht ersetzbare GUI-Plattform hast,
dann let's go, 10.000 Euro per App, per Plattform.
Das ist vielleicht nicht wirklich was für...
Ah ja, nice.
Man kann auch was für 20.000 Euro kaufen.
Das ist vielleicht nicht wirklich was für den gemeinen Open-Source-Entwickler,
aber für irgendwelche Business-Enterprise-Dinger, warum nicht?
Ja.
Also, WPF ist eine Windows-Only-Technologie,
die auf DirectX basiert,
zum Malen von Controls im Fenster.
Und MAUI benutzt zwar auch XAML,
zum Definieren, wie dein UI aussehen soll,
benutzt aber die jeweiligen Plattform-Native-Control-Elemente.
Also, GTK...
Nee, Moment, MAUI unterstützt ja offiziell gar kein Linux.
Also, wahrscheinlich WinUI unter Windows und...
Cocoa, oder wie das heißt, unter Mac.
Und das Android-UI-Kit unter Android und so.
Also, es ist...
Hat Überschneidung, ist aber von der Technik unten drunter was komplett anderes.
So, ich mach mal kurz VM-Updates.
Machen wir immer sonntags morgens.
Ich hab's zwar gestern schon gemacht,
aber Rolling Release Arch, by the way,
da kann das schon mal passieren,
dass es ein bisschen öfters Package-Updates gibt.
Ach, und ich muss meine Snapshots löschen.
Wie, darf ich das nicht?
Okay, kann ich.
Nö, hab ich noch nicht verwendet.
Weiß gar nicht, was das ist.
Jint.
Was ist Jint?
GitHub bestimmt, ne?
JavaScript-Interpreter für .NET.
Ach, da kannst du quasi deine Programme scriptbar machen oder sowas.
Ja.
Also, wenn man ein Programm hat, was von sowas profitiert, warum nicht?
Könnte man quasi so eine Art Plugins damit erstellen lassen.
So, machen wir mal kurz Package-Updates.
Nur Terraform, okay.
Und ansonsten auch nix, nice.
Okay, dann lösche ich mal meine Snapshots,
weil
die irgendwie ein bisschen groß werden einfach mit der Zeit.
Gestern ist ja nix kaputt gegangen, da brauch ich den Snapshot nicht.
Hab ich nur mal gemacht, weil ich den Snapshot nicht brauch.
Hab ich nur mal gemacht, bevor ich mir das ganze Java-Zeug installiert hab,
hab ich mal einen Snapshot gemacht.
Man weiß ja nie, ja.
Aber gab ja keine Probleme.
Und ich muss jetzt im Nachhinein sagen, nochmal so zu dem Stream gestern.
Also, Kortlin an sich hat auf mich einen wirklich guten Eindruck gemacht als Programmiersprache.
Es hat vielleicht für meinen Geschmack ein bisschen viel Sonderzeichen
und Sonderlocken an manchen Stellen, ja.
So mit das da für, als irgendwie so Blockeinrücker, Blockeinrückungs-Dings manchmal.
Ja, das war es eigentlich schon.
Oder auch Return-Times wieder so mit Doppelpunkt.
Aber das ist alles Gewöhnungssache.
Also, Kortlin hat auf mich gestern wirklich einen guten Eindruck gemacht.
Was auf mich keinen guten Eindruck gemacht hat, ist das Java-Ökosystem.
Das hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Ich warte seit drei Jahren auf das Resultat des Vorfalls aus dem Easy-Money-Video.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, was du meinst.
Schon mal Clojure ausprobiert?
Ne.
Auch nicht Scala.
Das Einzige, was ich mal ein bisschen machen musste, kann man fast schon nennen, war auf der alten Arbeit.
Ach das, der Typ hat gewonnen.
Der Typ hat gewonnen, aber Nokia muss es ihm nicht ausbezahlen.
Nokia muss es ihm nicht ausbezahlen.
Da gab es so ein komisches...
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Der hat gewonnen, aber er kriegt doch kein Geld.
Irgendwie sowas.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Es hat sich im Endeffekt irgendwie nicht richtig gelohnt.
Aber ich glaube unterm Strich hat er gewonnen.
Der hat gewonnen, aber wie war denn der Ausgang davon?
Suchen wir doch mal.
O2-Klage?
Ich muss mir nur noch mal raussuchen.
Das interessiert mich jetzt auch, was das gewesen ist hier.
Ich glaube, das war nur, dass der Rabatt nicht verfallen darf.
Also ich bin mir relativ sicher, nicht GitHub.
Guthaben.
Hier.
Mit der Aktion Easy-Money.
Kunde bekommt 225.000 Euro Rabattguthaben ausbezahlt.
Okay, der bekommt das wirklich ausbezahlt.
Dann habe ich jetzt falsche Erinnerungen.
Ich wusste nur, dass der Testertyp gewonnen hat.
Seine Kunden waren pro Anruf 2 Cent.
Doch, der Mobil sperrt die Karten vor Gericht.
Wollte der Mann, das hat mehr als 300.000 Euro gekostet.
Okay.
Also er hat nicht so viel bekommen, wie er wollte,
aber trotzdem ordentlich Money.
Ja.
Also er hat ein bisschen weniger gekriegt, als er gefordert hat,
aber er hat gewonnen.
Wie gesagt, das hatte ich auch noch im Hinterkopf,
dass der Typ gewonnen hat.
So, wo sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich stehen geblieben?
Ey, ich habe Package-Updates gemacht.
Nichts eigentlich.
Reboot hilft immer.
Ja, Chat, wenn jetzt die Leute,
jetzt sind ja schon die ersten Leute am Start hier.
Kennt ihr irgendeine gute Weekly-IT-News-Zusammenfassung?
Kann auf Englisch, Deutsch,
da kann auch Video oder Textform sein.
Ich kenne nichts, was mir gefällt.
Kennt da jemand irgendwas Gutes?
Also,
ich,
selbst eine Hacker-News-Zusammenfassung
wäre schon mal ganz cool.
Da gab es ja früher welche,
aber die gibt es ja nicht mehr.
Also irgendeine gescheite IT-News-Summary für die Woche.
Ah, Twitter.
Auf Twitter gibt es halt auch nur Leute,
die was schreiben, random,
aber halt nicht jemand, der sich hinsetzt
und mal eine interessante Zusammenfassung schreibt
für die Woche.
Früher hatte Heise sowas,
aber das gibt es irgendwie nicht mehr
und sowas würde ich mir tatsächlich wünschen, ja.
Ich gucke zwar trotzdem jeden Tag auf die Seite rauf,
aber man kriegt PC-Welt mit.
Oder?
Oder auf irgendeinem anderen Channel von ihm vielleicht.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ist das AI-generiert?
Na, ich weiß nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht.
Macht er nicht mehr.
Aber Heise,
Heise hat keine Weekly-Zusammenfassung mehr.
Die hatten mal sowas.
Wo hat Heise eine?
Also entweder
hat das Heise ganz blöde
versteckt
oder
es gibt es nicht mehr.
Die hatten vor zwei, drei Jahren hatten die eine.
Wo? Wo? Hier, Newsticker.
So.
Oder gibt sie es Sonntagabend?
Das kann natürlich auch sein,
aber Sonntagabend ist halt doof für mich so.
Ich brauche die sonntags morgens.
Gucken wir mal,
letzten Sonntag kam da irgendwas?
Nö.
Die haben keine Wochenzusammenfassung mehr.
Oder zumindest so versteckt,
dass ich nicht wüsste, wo sie ist.
Die haben manchmal Tageszusammenfassungen.
Computerbase hat in den Wochen.
Ja gut, Computerbase hat wahrscheinlich eher
welche Hardware-Tests und sowas sie die Woche hatten.
Also.
Ich wüsste nicht mehr, wo Heise eins hat.
Und Golem hat auch keine Wochen.
Nicht Holem, Alter.
Wer weiß auf welche Seite ich da jetzt gekommen wäre.
Hat auch keine Wochenzusammenfassung.
Oder wenn dann auch so
schlecht
promoted,
dass ich nicht weiß, wo sie ist.
Ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Gibt es irgendwie nicht.
Mir persönlich wäre es ja fast sogar
ein Ticken lieber, als wäre in Videoform.
Ey.
Ja, Leute.
Wie gesagt, Google suchen kann ich auch.
Der Golem Wochenrückblick.
Wann kommt denn der?
Ah, nice.
Der Wochenrückblick ist so aktuell,
dass wir auf den 16. zurückblicken.
Top.
Und es ist von 2022.
Das gibt es halt irgendwie nicht.
Das ist halt.
Es sackt irgendwie.
Keine Ahnung, dabei fände ich das ganz praktisch.
Da könnten wir nämlich einmal
Sonntagmorgens mal kurz überfliegen,
was wir die Woche vielleicht verpasst haben.
Aber es gibt irgendwie nichts.
Und wie gesagt, mir ist egal,
ob auf Deutsch, auf Englisch, in Textform
oder in Videoform.
Vielleicht auf Englisch in Videoform,
international in Videoform,
aber in deutscher Videoform wäre auch okay.
Videoform ist halt das Ding.
Da kannst du vielleicht 10 News reinnehmen,
dann ist das Video voll
und dann müsste es halt auch jemand sein,
der sich für genau die Sachen interessiert,
wo ich mich für interessiere.
Demnächst der Woblos IT.
Ja, dafür kriege ich nicht genug mit.
Ich will ja einen IT-Wochen-News-Überblick,
weil ich selbst nicht alles mitkriege.
Das Einzige, was ich die Woche mitbekommen habe,
ist diese Geschichte.
Was ich mitgekriegt habe,
was ein bisschen größere Kreise gezogen hat.
Was auch, witzigerweise,
noch nicht so große Kreise gezogen hat,
wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Und das ist ja eigentlich auch schon
eher eine letzte Woche News,
oder eigentlich sogar eine 14-Tage-News.
Heise Plus werde ich nie wieder ausprobieren.
Ich habe mich einmal für Heise Plus angemeldet
und dann ging das Kündigen über das Webinterface nicht mehr.
Da musste ich eine E-Mail schreiben,
so richtig wie 1995.
How to create this unbelievable CSS-Scroll-Animation.
Unbelievable.
Hat er eine Wochenzusammenfassung?
Ich kenne nur die Videos von ihm,
die gucken wir ja ab und zu auch,
wo die ersten 2-3 Minuten
die eigentliche interessante Sache kommt.
Und danach kommt noch 10-15 Minuten Gerante
über, keine Ahnung, Sachen, die in der Cloud gespeichert werden,
nicht Open-Source-Software und sonst was.
Ich teile viele seiner Ansichten,
aber man muss nicht jedes Video
da erstmal eine Viertelstunde drüber uprenden.
Er hat ja oftmals sogar recht.
Aber ich glaube nicht,
dass der IT-News-Wochenübersicht...
Na gut.
So, lass mal schauen, was können wir uns angucken.
Ein typischer Tag als Software-Entwickler.
Übrigens, vorhin wurde mir dieses Video empfohlen.
Keine Ahnung, warum.
Wir bilden aus,
die Universität zu Köln
bildet Fachinformatiker für Anwendungsentwickler aus.
Mal gucken, was die so zu bieten haben.
Absolutes Banger-Video.
60 Views, 0 Comments.
Aber YouTube war der Meinung,
Max, das musst du sehen.
Und, wo YouTube auch der Meinung war,
dass ich das sehen muss,
ist das hier.
Undercover in ApoReds-Abzockgruppe.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ey.
Der frühe Hase, Alter.
Du wirst es nicht sehen,
der frühe Hase, Alter.
Du hast nix verpasst.
Gar nix.
Wir haben grad GitHub geguckt und das war's.
Sonst haben wir noch nix gemacht.
War immer eigentlich neu gestartet, ja.
Nice.
PayPal ist auch am Start.
Nochmal so als Hinweis,
weil das öfters mal kommt,
auch als Frage,
wo gibt es die Desktop-Hintergründe?
Wer die Desktop-Hintergründe nice findet,
der findet die hier über mir auf GitHub.
Da gibt es für jede Tageszeit
einen passenden Hintergrund.
Mittag essen, Keks futtern, arbeiten,
Booster trinken,
ganz wichtig, Nudeln mit Lachs futtern,
bügeln,
Workouten,
ohne was für weitere Bilder,
Frühstücken,
warmer Kaffee,
Cornflakes,
weiß ja nicht, Cornflakes sind ja eher
so Fruit Loops,
oder wie der Kempel heißt,
schläft da auch noch
und träumt von so Sachen wie PAP,
abends putzt er Zähne
oder guckt meine YouTube-Videos
und hier geht er gleich ins Bett.
Gibt es für alle Tageszeiten
ein passendes PayPal-Background-Bild.
Und es ist auch ein Skript,
also wer Linux verwendet,
kann auch hier das Background-Skript verwenden,
was quasi alle Tageszeiten
passend
die Hintergrund-Bild ersetzt haben.
Also das ist ja auch folgendermaßen entstanden,
ich hatte ganz lang
den Windows XP,
den ganz normalen Windows XP-Hügel als Hintergrund,
so,
hab ich hier immer noch.
Irgendwann hat dann einer ein Bild gepostet
mit dem White Paper im Hintergrund
hier über dem XP-Hügel
und dann hatte ich die Idee,
man könnte doch
den für jede Tageszeit anpassen
und dann hat sich der Rackman aus dem Chat gemeldet
und hat gesagt,
der kann ein paar Hintergründe erstellen
und so ist das entstanden.
Okay, mit was fangen wir an?
Ein typischer Unternehmen, komm.
Leute,
wenn wir das Video hier aus dem Weg kriegen,
die Universität Köln
sucht Fachinformatiker
und das sind eineinhalb Minuten Videos,
wo sie hoffentlich dafür werben,
zu ihnen zu kommen als
Physi, äh, nicht Physi,
FIAE-Entwickler, äh, aus Azubi.
Tomox, danke für den Sub.
Bin ich mal gespannt,
was die Uni Köln
erzählt, um das den Leuten schmackhaft zu machen,
warum man zu ihnen gehen soll.
Schauen wir mal.
Das könnte das ultra langweiligste Video ever werden,
aber gucken wir mal.
Okay, fängt ja schon sehr enthusiastisch an.
Was macht der?
ZFL?
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Was ist ZFL?
Zentrum für Lehrkräftebildung.
Ach, du Schei...
Okay, das hätte ich jetzt nicht gewusst.
Ich dachte, das ist irgendwas,
sowas wie ZFS.
ZFL.
Hi, ich bin Arman Gülcek,
ich bin ebenfalls Azubi für Anwendungsentwicklung
am ZFL an der Uni Köln.
ZFL, okay.
Hallo, ich bin Jan Wieners,
Ausbilder am ZFL für Fachinformatikerin...
Oh, mehr Resident Sleeper
hättet ihr das Video aber nicht machen können,
Universität Köln, oder?
...und Fachinformatiker im Bereich der Anwendungsentwicklung.
Wir betreuen hier Lehramtsstudierende
in ihrem Studium,
damit sie sich bestmöglich für die Zukunftschancen
von Kindern und Jugendlichen einsetzen können.
Resident Sleeper.
Moment, die sitzen draußen auf irgendeiner Schaukel
mit dem Laptop.
Das haben die doch jetzt eigentlich auch
normalerweise bestimmt auch im Büro.
...studieren im Lehramt
an einer der vier lehrerinnenbildenden
Fakultäten der Universität.
Immerhin Hardtop im Hintergrund auf.
So muss das sein.
Das ist doch eindeutig Hardtop, oder?
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ja, 100 Pro.
Nice, nice Hardtop-Monitoring.
...oder an einer der kooperierenden Hochschulen.
Erstmal
der Heavy-Metal-Azubi,
so mag ich das.
Das sind die Deutsche Sporthochschule
und die Hochschule für Musik und Tanz.
Das ZFL ist für die Lehramtsstudierenden
die zentrale Einrichtung in Köln.
Das Video ist so langweilig,
da würde ich mich nicht bewerben.
Aber schönes T-Shirt.
Der Metal-Azubi.
Sehr vielfältig.
Wir entwickeln gemeinsam mit anderen Teams Projekte.
Und Low-Profile-Tastaturen.
EGIT.
Ein kürzlich abgeschlossenes Projekt
ist das Einkaufstool.
Chat-Gear.
Import.
Was ist denn das?
Javascript ist das, gell?
Angular!
Das ist Angular.
Lustig.
Sascha und ich haben sehr viel Spaß gehabt
an der Programmierung des Einkaufstools.
Das Einkaufstool ist eine Web-Anwendung,
die dafür da ist...
Aber immerhin, guck mal hier,
ordentlich komplexes Ding.
...beschaffungen bzw. Einkäufe
für sowas.
Warum muss man sowas jetzt mal
selbst entwickeln?
Sowas gibt es doch schon tausendfach fertig
und es muss nicht gleich SAP sein,
wenn man sich da nicht die Pest
ins Unternehmen holen will.
Also,
kann kommen.
Die kenne ich.
Witzig.
Den hatte ich auch schon was zu tun.
...Einkäufe von verschiedenen Teams.
Hast du Lust, ein Teil unserer IT zu werden?
Du hast ein Fach Oberschule,
reife und du beschäftigst dich
in deiner Freizeit mit Informatik?
Fach Oberschule, reife heißt,
das heißt, du musst Abi haben, oder?
...Einkäufe.
Hast du Lust, ein Teil unserer IT zu werden?
Du hast ein Fach Oberschule, reife
und du beschäftigst dich
in deiner Freizeit mit Informatik?
Dann bin ich doch bei uns.
Wir freuen uns.
Das sah sehr überzeugend aus.
Okay, wahrscheinlich sind die
gar keine schlechte Ausbildungsbetrieb,
aber das Video war
sehr interessant.
Ich habe noch was von PC-Welt.
Es gibt ein TechUp Weekly.
Aber PC-Welt, Alter.
Also, über PC-Welt bin ich
eigentlich schon drüber hinaus.
Okay, das muss ich jetzt mal
aber checken, ob das was taugt.
PC-Welt TechUp Weekly.
Ach, Moment, das ist ein Video.
Okay, was haben die da so für Themen?
Vor zwei Jahren, nice.
Gibt es nicht mehr.
Okay, die bilden auch Physis aus.
Okay, lass uns mal kurz gucken,
wie Fachinformatiker anhören
zur Entwicklung bei denen.
Ich bin Philipp und absolviere
die Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker
für Systemindikation.
Diese dreijährige Ausbildung
kannst du an vielen verschiedenen
Standorten an der Uni Köln machen.
Das fängt ja genauso
Resident Sleeper an wie das andere.
Und schöne YouTube-Generic-Happy-Music.
Hast du Spaß an der neuesten IT-Technik
und löst gerne Probleme am PC?
Dann zeige ich dir mal etwas
aus meinem Alltag an der Uni Köln.
Die Einrichtung, den Aufbau
und die Pflege von IT-Systemen.
Für mehr als 50.000 Studierende...
Ich meine, mehr Generic könnte man
auch die Physi-Beschreibung nicht machen, oder?
Die Aufbau, Wartung und Blablabla
von IT-Systemen.
...den Aufbau und die Pflege
Für mehr als 50.000 Studierende
und 7.000 Mitarbeiter stellen wir
Hardware und Software zur Verfügung.
Hi, ich bin Corinna Böschenbröker,
Ausbildungskoordinatorin für die IT-Berufe.
Deine Ausbildung kennst du entweder
beim IT-Service...
Sag mal, lesen die den Text
hinter der Kamera ab?
...oder bei einer zentralen Einrichtung,
wie zum Beispiel hier am IT-Center machen.
Hier sind wir jetzt in der Serverhalle
der Universität zu Köln.
Die Serverhalle!
Die Server stellen Ressourcen...
Rechenzentrum ist out!
...bei Netzwerken zur Verfügung,
zum Beispiel für zentrale Systeme wie Mail...
Ich werde das aber jetzt auch immer
Serverhalle nennen.
Ich finde die Bezeichnung zu geil,
das Rechenzentrum ist so 0815.
Serverhalle!
Das klingt fast so ein bisschen wie
ich gehe jetzt in die Kirche
oder sowas und gucke mir das an.
Wenn Probleme bei der Bereitstellung
auftreten, dann helfen unsere
Fachinformatikerinnen und
Fachinformatiker diese zu lösen.
Hast du Lust Teil unserer IT-Welt
an der Universität zu sein?
Du hast mindestens die Fachoberschulreife
und hast dich in deiner Freizeit
bereits mit IT beschäftigt?
Dann bewirb dich!
Okay, man hätte das Video durchaus
weniger Resident Sleeper machen können.
Wir suchen genau dich.
Naja, okay.
Physis suchen die auch.
Die suchen jede Menge anscheinend.
Sieht mir für dich echt,
da sah was nach Grafana aus,
so genau habe ich nicht geguckt.
Ich habe einmal Hardtop im Hintergrund
gesehen und irgendeine selbstgebaute
Angular-Web-Anwendung.
Beim Physi habe ich gar nicht
das Gefühl.
Erstens würde ich nie so etwas
machen wollen und zweitens
könnte ich das auch nicht und
drittens hätte ich da eigentlich
keinen Bock drauf.
Wie hast du das gefunden?
Wurde dir das zufällig von
YouTube empfohlen oder bist du
über YouTube da?
Also ich lese das so raus,
dass dir das zufällig von Twitch
empfohlen wurde.
Da hat als Voraussetzung beim
Anwendungsentwickler war,
dass es ein typischer Tag
als auf Abored.
Okay Leute, wir müssen jetzt
leiden, Leute da müssen wir
jetzt durch, mich interessiert was
Abored macht.
Wir müssen uns jetzt das Video
hier angucken.
Undercover in Aboreds Abzockgruppe.
Der echte frühe kritische Hase
ist am Start.
Mal gucken, was nach dem
Insi-Modus so passiert ist.
Normalerweise gucken wir ja nicht
solche Videos, aber wenn mir das
jemand interessiert, was Abored so
macht, muss das jetzt sein.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich schon total
outdated, overrated, shebaited.
Ich meine das Video ist drei Tage
raus und hat 333.000 Views.
Wahrscheinlich der letzte auf der
Welt, der sich das anguckt.
Aber mal gucken, was Abored so
treibt.
Das reicht mir das Intro ja schon.
Lass mich raten.
Abored hat jetzt eine WhatsApp-Gruppe.
Irgendwie drei Jahre nachdem
das mal angesagt war.
Alter, jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Vom Insi-Modus zum
Finanzberater oder wie.
Also da habe ich schon glaubhaftere
Dinger gesehen.
Das passt ja nun wirklich gar nicht
zusammen.
Ich habe vor zwei Tagen einfach 900
Euro gemacht, indem ich einfach
seine Trades kopiert habe.
Ach ne, er macht Werbung für
irgendwas anderes.
Okay.
Na klar.
Alter, warum fällt...
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Warum fällt auf diesen
Komm-in-die-Gruppe-Kram überhaupt
noch irgendjemand rein?
Kann mir das jemand schlüssig
erklären?
Ich dachte, also angefangen hat
der ganze Campbell ja irgendwie
schon vor fünf Jahren oder so.
Und damals war eigentlich schon
jedem normal denkenden Mensch klar,
das ist Scam.
Warum gibt es das in 2023
noch und es funktioniert?
Ich verstehe es einfach nicht.
Es leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Bin ich in die Gruppe gegangen.
Und damit moin Leute, herzlich willkommen
hier zurück zu diesem wunderschönen
neuen Video hier wieder auf meinem Kanal.
Schön, dass du wieder dabei bist.
Ich saß letztens zu Hause und dachte
mir, was macht eigentlich ApoRed gerade?
Genau das habe ich mir auch gedacht,
als mir das Video vorgeschlagen wurde
heute Morgen.
Das war die Instagram-Story von
ihm, die schon so bodenlos war,
dass es beim Zusehen schon unangenehm
wird. Man hat von ApoRed ja lange
nichts mehr gehört, seitdem Mimi
aufgedeckt hat, dass der Typ
eigentlich komplett insolvent ist
und in einer Sozialwohnung lebt.
Jetzt hat sich ApoRed aber wieder
zurückgemeldet, zuerst vor kurzem
auf YouTube. Dort hat er uns nämlich
erzählt, dass er in Dubai chillt.
Dubai ist die neue Meta.
Das Video habe ich auch gesehen.
Also nicht gesehen, also den Titel
des Videos taucht auch dieser Typ
hier auf. Das ist Lukas und er
erzählt uns noch später im Video.
Findet ihr nicht auch, dass wenn man
sich die zwei Jungs da auf dem
Sofa so anguckt, findet ihr nicht
auch, dass man denen doch sofort
eigentlich komplett euer komplettes
Geld anvertrauen sollte? Ich finde,
dass die beiden strahlen einfach
schon so eine Vertrauenswürdigkeit
aus. Ich würde einfach instant die
Überweisung machen. Schon beim ersten
Mal sehen, sofort. Die sehen einfach so
vertrauenswürdig aus, direkt. Was hat
er da eigentlich in der Hand? So eine
Wasserpfeife oder sowas. Was der
eigentlich so macht? Mein Job im Endeffekt
nennt sich Currency Trader, Aktien
Trader, wie auch immer man sagen will.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, du bist in den
Finanzmärkten und handelst, kaufst unten
ein, verkaufst oben oder andersrum,
machst dein Geld dann im Profil. Und
dann plötzlich geht es doch sehr viel
ums Traden und ApoRed hat da doch die
eine oder andere Nachfrage. Aber Trading
ist so, ich persönlich kann damit nichts
anfangen. Also ich höre Trading, ich denke
mir so, irgendwie so kaufen. Irgendwie,
ich wollte es gerade sagen, irgendwie
erinnern mich diese ganzen Sachen immer
ein bisschen an BITCONNECT. Diese ganzen
Scam-Dinger, das ist doch alles der
gleiche Shit. Ich habe es bei BITCONNECT
auch nie verstanden, warum Leute
ernsthaft gedacht haben nach dieser
Präsentation hier. Carlos Martos von New
York City. Nach diesem Intro, dass
Leute sich gedacht haben. Findet ihr
nicht auch, das wirkt so seriös, dass
ihr alle eure Kohle dahin überweisen
wollt direkt? BITCONNECT. Findet ihr
nicht auch, dass das so seriös wirkt,
dass ihr alle eure Kohle da sofort die
ganze Kohle hin überweisen will? Ich
habe das das erste Mal gesehen und
dachte mir gleich. Alter, wer macht denn
sowas? Aber genug! Und das ist hier das
gleiche. Es gibt genug. Die stecken ein
Da ihr.... ich verstehe es nicht. Keine
Ahnung. Ich dachte eigentlich mittlerweile
sollte es jeder gecheckt haben. Aber
anscheinend nicht. Ich mache auch direkt
die Überweisung klar, ja. Nein, das...
Okay, Leute, ich predikt dir jetzt mal die Antwort, was da drauf kommt.
Irgendwie so kaufen, an dem Zeitpunkt holen, verkaufen. Ist das brutal schwer?
Ich predikt dir jetzt mal die Antwort. Er sagt, nein, das ist ganz einfach.
Du kommst einfach zu mir in die Gruppe und da gibt's dann die krassen Trading-Tipps und du wirst easy reich.
Sowas in der Richtung würde er jetzt antworten.
Kann man das lernen oder ist es unmöglich, easy peasy?
Zum Glück erklärt uns Lukas das alles.
Du brauchst irgendjemanden, der dir zumindest eine Guideline gibt.
Aber jetzt bist du ja Experte. Sonst würdest du ja nicht viereinhalb Jahre jetzt hier leben.
Ja, und plötzlich fühlt sich das irgendwie wie so ein Verkaufsgespräch an.
Aber sagen wir es als Beispiel auf lustig. Ich nehme jetzt einfach mal so 5.000 Euronen oder so.
Kannst du mir helfen? Freund ist mir egal. Ich jump mit 5.000 Euronen rein.
Ja, okay.
Moment. Woher hat ApoRed 5.000 Euro locker?
Es riecht mir fast so ein bisschen nach einer Paid Promotion.
Hm, könnte das vielleicht sein?
ApoRed ist drin.
Ah, 5.000 Euro, da klingelt's in der Kasse.
Woher auch immer diese 5.000 Euro kommen, wenn man in...
Das habe ich mich auch gerade gefragt. Woher hat er irgendwie diese 5.000 Euro?
Hat er nicht den Insi-Modus noch laufen?
...Deutschland eigentlich insolvent ist? Naja.
Und ApoRed ist hier wirklich der zuvorkommende Hase, der uns auch alle nötigen Informationen und Links...
Er sollte vielleicht ein bisschen mehr der kritische Hase sein in der Situation.
...damit wir auch direkt mitmachen können.
Ja, SpeedDuck, es muss heute einfach mal sein. Mich interessiert, was ApoRed macht.
Normalerweise gucken wir solche Videos nicht.
Aber das wird mir vorgeschlagen und irgendwie interessiert es mich, was er so treibt.
Ich mach den Link zur Telegram-Gruppe rein.
Ich verlinke mal seine Group.
Link ist oben in der Beschreibung, Freunde.
Ja, praktisch. Vielen Dank dafür.
Das wirkt ja überhaupt nicht aufgesetzt, dass plötzlich 5.000 Euro investiert werden.
Ich finde, das klingt einfach super seriös. Ich weiß gar nicht, was er hat.
Chat, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht. Also ich hätte da überhaupt keine Bedenken jetzt.
Ein bisschen skeptisch bei der ganzen Sache.
Ich mein, ApoRed ist ja generell der absolut seriöseste Influencer aller Zeiten.
Wie könnte das irgendwie was nicht nennen? Das kann nicht sein.
...Sache und hab dann ne Insta-Story gesehen, paar Tage später, wo es dann weiter ging.
Wieder ApoRed und...
Erinnert sich noch einer an den Bomben-Prank?
Auch in Dubai, natürlich.
Und da erzählt uns ApoRed, wie erfolgreich er mit diesen geilen Tipps bisher schon war.
Ich hab vor zwei Tagen einfach 900 Euro gemacht, indem ich einfach seine Trades kopiert habe von der Gruppe, Freunde.
Ah, ja krass. Das ist aber ein Zufall.
Aber nicht nur ApoRed, sondern auch die Leute.
Die erst seit kurzem in der Gruppe sind.
Sollen schon richtig dick Kohle damit gemacht haben.
Tobi ist vor ein paar Tagen in die Gruppe gekommen. 1800 Euro Profit.
Sehen wir hier Dominik, 150...
Da stand doch was anderes, oder?
Einfach 1800...
Da steht 1800, er erzählt irgendwas anderes gerade, oder?
...100 Euro Profit.
Sehen wir hier Dominik, 150 Scheine gemacht.
18 Prozent. Hassan kommt rein.
110 Euro.
Oder...
Du musst einfach...
Hassan geht in die Gruppe.
Instant 1500 Euro.
Du musst nur joinen, Leute. Instant.
Ich erkenne gar nichts.
Achso, ja, Leute. Übrigens, ich habe auch eine Tradinggruppe aufgemacht.
Und wie man hier erkennen kann, haben die Leute da drin mit cleverem Investieren 7 Milliarden Dollar Umsatz gemacht.
Hier.
Davor sagt man dann noch solche Sätze.
Leute lügen, aber Resultate nicht.
Ja, und man versucht mit sowas natürlich Vertrauen bei den Leuten aufzunehmen.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob man irgendwo die Resultate auch sehen kann.
Also, ich meine, wenn das ja so super erfolgreich ist und alles so gut läuft,
wird man ja dann sicherlich auch recht, wie soll man sagen, offen mit irgendwelchen Statistiken umgehen, oder?
Dass man sehen kann, ja, guck mal hier, das kann doch gar nicht gelogen sein.
Hier steht es ja, das muss ja stimmen.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich muss jetzt mal eins sagen.
Also, ich bin, glaube ich, der langweiligste Stonkskäufer aller Zeiten.
Ich habe nur einen ETF, sonst nichts.
Das kann man wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal, kann man das Aktien nennen überhaupt?
Ja, schon, aber halt nicht direkt gekauft, sondern über einen ETF.
So, und sogar ich habe in diesem Monat, in einem Monat, ist es gestiegen um 1400 Euro.
So, und das ist nur von so einem publichen ETF.
Also, in diesem Monat hier ist es wirklich sehr günstig gewesen, Kohle zu machen.
Also, sehr easy muss das gewesen sein, Kohle zu machen.
Weil, wenn ich mit meinem Publichen World ETF schon 1400 Euro, wie viel ich da hab?
Also, in dem, ok, das kann ich dir sagen.
Ich habe, wo steht denn das hier?
Broker, ich sag's dir.
Ich sag's dir, Broker, Portfolio und dann aus dem Portfolio den All World,
jetzt läuft es durch, jetzt kann ich euch nicht vorlesen, was es für ein ETF ist.
Hier, Vanguard, jetzt läuft es nicht mehr weiter, ok.
Vanguard, PLC, ah jetzt doch.
FTSE, All World, UCITS, ETF, USD, also Dollar, Accumulating.
So, und da habe ich zur Zeit 37.376 Euro.
In diesem da drinnen.
So, und wenn ich den anklicke und stelle den auf für einen Monat,
dann ist es plus 4,08 Prozent, ne, ups, hä, Moment.
Ach ne, das ist jetzt das einzelne Ding, ich muss insgesamt gucken.
Ok, genau, in einem Monat 1416 Euro.
So, das heißt aber ja noch lange nicht, dass ich das jetzt auch bekomme.
Das würde ich bekommen, wenn ich den Kram jetzt verkaufe.
Das kann durchaus sein, dass es in zwei Jahren ganz anders aussieht,
entweder viel mehr oder viel weniger.
Das Schöne an dem ETF ist, der schwankt halt nicht so krass.
Dementsprechend machst du da auch jetzt nicht in einem Tag super viel Plus
und in einem super viel Minus, sondern es ist eher was langfristiges.
Mein Plan ist ja, ich bezahle noch ein bisschen weiter auf meine ETFs ein,
beziehungsweise auf meinen, also sehr nicht mein ETF.
Irgendwann, da lasse ich das Geld liegen und irgendwann,
wenn ich in Rente gehen will, bin ich reich.
Was wahrscheinlich nicht so kommen wird, aber ja.
Darüber machst du das über Scalable.
Aber lass uns mal den kritischen Hasen, der muss uns weiter erklären, wie das ist.
Also was ich nur sagen wollte ist, es ist nicht so schwer gewesen,
im letzten Monat Kohle zu machen.
Wenn sogar mein publischer ETF gestiegen ist in dem Ausmaß.
Den ich absolut nichts erkennen kann.
Nee, stimmt, das kann auf jeden Fall nicht gelogen sein.
Und dann versucht man noch das Gefühl davon zu erzeugen,
dass hier wirklich ein sehr, sehr gefragtes Angebot ist.
Ich würde das voll bombardieren, tausende Nachrichten,
er wird voll gespammt, jeder will rein, weil es einfach for free ist.
Klar, damit möchte man natürlich...
Selbstverständlich.
...würde ich bei den Leuten ein Fear of Missing Out Gefühl erzeugen.
Dass das hier der neue heiße Scheiß ist, bei dem man unbedingt dabei sein muss
und richtig viel verpasst, wenn man es nicht tut.
Ja, keine Ahnung, bei wem das so klappt.
Ach so, es sind mehrere tausend Interessenten.
Ah, nicht, dass ich da noch zu spät komme.
Aber irgendwie kann ich dann doch noch mitmachen.
Leute, ich sag ganz ehrlich, wir können jetzt nur noch 10 Leute kostenlos mit reinpacken.
Danach muss ich die Gruppe schließen.
Wisst ihr, was ich mich immer so frage?
Also unabhängig davon, dass es mittlerweile jedem klar sein sollte,
dass es offensichtlicher Scam, kann man es eigentlich schon nennen, ist.
Was ich mich immer frage ist, in diesen Videos,
die Leute machen immer so kompletten krassen Lifestyle, 24-7.
Und ich frage mich dann so, wann machen die eigentlich Trading und verdienen ihr Geld?
Weil es ist jetzt ja nicht so, als könnte man sich da einfach mal hinsetzen,
mal kurz morgens irgendwelche Aktienkurse durchscrollen und sagen,
oh ja, kaufen wir heute mal eine Runde Amazon und Apple und dann bam, 8.000 Euro verdient.
Das ist ja blödsinnig.
Das funktioniert ja so nicht.
Aber nachdem die den ganzen Tag 24-7 Lifestyle machen,
zumindest wird das in den Videos immer dargestellt,
fragt man sich, ja wann arbeiten und traden die eigentlich?
Also ihr wisst ja, ich habe bei einer Bank gearbeitet.
Und ich kenne tatsächlich ein paar Trader persönlich.
Das ist furchtbar langweilig, die sitzen den ganzen Tag vorm Computer.
Und die machen nicht den krassen Lifestyle in Dubai.
Also insofern ist das gar kein so krasser Lifestyle-Job anscheinend,
wenn man das hauptberuflich macht.
Wir können jetzt nur noch 10 Leute kostenlos mit reinpacken.
Danach muss ich die Gruppe schließen.
Warum? Warum können ausgerechnet nur 10 Leute noch in die Gruppe?
Warum nicht 11?
Was würde eine Person für einen Unterschied machen?
Es ist aber ärgerlich, dass diese Gruppe dann geschlossen wird.
Nur noch jetzt die Möglichkeit dazu.
So ganz konnte ich das nicht glauben.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, probierst du es einfach mal aus.
Also bin ich auf den Link gegangen und dachte mir,
reingeht es in die Gruppe.
Und sehe da, die Gruppe hat fast 6.000 Mitglieder und ich wurde angenommen.
Irgendwie passen doch mehr als 10 Leute rein, habe ich das Gefühl.
Die Gruppe wurde übrigens am 19. Juni gegründet.
Und schon in der ersten Nachricht wurde gesagt,
dass ein Teilnehmer 4.000 Euro damit verdient hat.
Bro, das ging schnell. Wo kommst du her?
Teilnehmer 4.000 Euro damit.
Schade, dass er nicht gehavert hat über diese Likes da unten.
Würde mich interessieren, wer da geliket hat
und ob es nicht immer wieder die gleichen Leute sind,
die es einfach fake liken.
Ach, es ist Telegram, es ist gar nicht WhatsApp, guck mal.
Sind WhatsApp-Gruppen nicht mehr angesagt?
Heute ist es Telegram.
...verdient hat.
Bro, das ging schnell. Wo kommst du her?
Und dann habe ich mich da einfach mal so durchgeklickt und geguckt,
was da so geschrieben wird.
Und immer wieder fällt auf, dass...
Lass mich, okay, ich predikte mal was, was da geschrieben wird.
Mir wird geschrieben, für den krassen Lifestyle
musst du das richtige Gewinner-Mindset haben,
das richtige Grindset, Mindset, High-Performer.
Lass dir nichts erzählen von irgendwelchen Low-Performer-Freunden.
Du hast drauf, du wirst das schaffen,
du musst das krasse Business machen.
Sowas wird da wahrscheinlich erzählt.
Also im Prinzip das,
was wahrscheinlich in 99% dieser Scams immer erzählt wird.
...gesagt wird, dass man ihn privat schreiben soll,
wenn man in die VIP-Gruppe kommen möchte.
Also wir sind hier wohl in der Billo-Gruppe
für den Pöbeln, das einfache Volk.
Aber die coolen Leute, die sind in der VIP-Gruppe.
Und es fällt auf, dass dieser ganze...
Das heißt, die krassen Trading-Tipps, die gibt es in der VIP-Gruppe.
...indem man hier drin ist auf Telegram,
eine einzige Werbeveranstaltung für diese VIP-Gruppe ist.
Also ApoRed-Chat ist relevant genug,
dass irgendwelche Leute mit ihm Telegram-Scams bewerben, ja?
Jeder zweiten Nachricht geht es darum.
Also da siehst du schon,
der hat noch immer genug Leute, die ihm zugucken.
Ich glaube, hat der nicht sogar einen neuen YouTube-Channel?
Hab ich irgendwas gesehen letztens sogar?
Ach, der Küser testet auch die ApoRed-Gruppe, okay.
Hat der nicht irgendeinen Fortnite-Channel oder sowas?
Das da, der echte, genau.
Ah, der macht seit einem Jahr nichts mehr.
Weil Insi-Modus wahrscheinlich.
Der Kaiser hat ein gutes Video zu mir.
Ja, es reicht mir aber danach.
Auch wenn ich den Kaiser tatsächlich...
Das ist der einzige, ohne Scheiß.
Das ist der einzige so...
Wie nennt man das so?
Entertainment-Style-Reaction.
Wie nennt man diese Sorte von YouTube-Sachen?
So auf aktuelle YouTube-Ereignisse reagieren
und ein bisschen sein Selbst zu geben.
Das ist der einzige, den ich gucken kann.
Weil ich den eigentlich ganz lustig finde
und er das immer gut rüberbringt alles.
Meinungsblogger.
Triffst du das wirklich?
Eigentlich fasst er das nur mehr oder weniger lustig zusammen.
Aber nennen wir es mal Meinungsblogger.
Das ist wirklich...
Das ist der einzige, den ich mir da angucken kann.
Den gucke ich auch tatsächlich ganz gerne,
weil ich mir regelmäßig an den Kopf greifen muss,
was da so abgeht.
Auch gerade irgendwelche TikTok-Influencer und so,
wenn ich unterwegs bin.
Ich bin der übelste Social-Media-Boomer,
wenn man das so will.
Ich benutze keinen TikTok
und ich hab keinen Instagram.
Die Leute interessieren mich auch überhaupt nicht.
Aber ich muss da teilweise echt hardcringen,
wenn ich die Videos sehe.
Aber lass uns das mal weitergucken.
Also was wird denn so geschrieben
in der VIP-Gruppe?
Ne, das ist doch nicht die...
Das ist gar nicht die VIP-Gruppe.
Das ist die normale Gruppe.
Die wollen, dass man in die VIP-Gruppe kommt.
Also die normale Gruppe bringt überhaupt gar nichts.
Wer hätte das nur vermuten können.
Du schreib mir doch endlich.
Nur noch 5 Plätze, nur noch 10 Plätze.
Ey, KuchenTV nervt mich.
Nicht KuchenTV persönlich,
sondern, dass ich die ganze Zeit irgendwelche
Empfehlungen kriege auf YouTube.
Äh, Schurioka verklagt KuchenTV.
KuchenTV reaktet.
Da kommen irgendwelche Leute, die auf die Reaction
der Reaction interessiert.
Das ist doch überhaupt nicht...
Dieser deutschsprachige YouTube-
Twitch-Beef, das geht mir
so am Arsch vorbei.
Und dann MontanaBlack reagiert drauf.
Dann reagiert irgendjemand
darauf, dass MontanaBlack reagiert hat.
Das geht mir so am Arsch vorbei.
Aber YouTube ist der Meinung, doch Max,
das muss dich interessieren, guck das jetzt mal gefälligst.
Da hab ich letztens doch tatsächlich
mal eines dieser Videos angeklickt.
Und da hab ich sofort
Leute hier aus dem Chat wiedergefunden.
Da war live Chat dabei.
Und da hab ich,
ich glaub dem ByteStrikes war das,
der hier auch manchmal im Chat rumkrebst.
Hab ich sofort im Chat wiedererkannt.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, Leute, was macht
der FiveHatChat
den ganzen Tag denn sonst, wenn er nicht gerade
FiveHat ist.
Deutsche Influencer sind mega cringe.
Also ich geh davon aus, dass
im englischsprachigen Bereich es
ähnlich abgehen wird. Da biefen sie
sich ja auch, aber das ist irgendwie so
so uninteressant
für mich, was da im deutschen Bereich, ich mein,
ich guck mir auch keine Yellowpress
und Boulevard so Sachen an oder
was im englischsprachigen Bereich abgeht.
Aber YouTube Deutschland ist halt irgendwie
der Meinung, ich will das gucken.
Nö, das rafft YouTube nicht.
Ich hab sogar manche Channels komplett
ausgeplanet und das juckt YouTube nicht
mir Content zu empfehlen, der mit
diesen Channels in Verbindung steht.
Das juckt die nicht.
Bin schon an den Charts.
Moment, Moment.
Wait a minute. Bin schon
an den Charts. Wenn du heute mit mir
traden willst, Komplettkost, schick mir eine Nachricht.
You ready? Sonnenbrille.
Gestern beim Lasern war...
Okay.
Also.
Man wird zum krassen Trader, wenn man so
5 Minuten am Tag mal einen Chart aufmacht.
Yeah, done. Easy.
Aber...
Was genau? Also...
Ich muss jetzt mal was sagen.
Also.
Wisst ihr, was eine Sache, die mir auffällt?
Bei diesen ganzen
Komm-in-die-Gruppe-Dingern.
Es muss nicht bei den ganzen
Komm-in-die-Gruppe-Dingern sein. Es reicht auch,
wenn es irgendwelche
Lifestyle-Coaches
oder
Du musst jetzt krasse Business
machen.
Komm und mach meine Seminare.
Coaches sind eine Sache, die mir immer
auffällt bei solchen Leuten.
Vielleicht tue ich jetzt auch dem einen oder anderen Unrecht,
aber dann sind sie selbst dran schuld, wenn sie sich da
so präsentieren, wie sie sich präsentieren.
Das einzige Wort...
Karl S. zum Beispiel ist auch so einer.
Das einzige Wort, was mir bei solchen Leuten
immer einfällt, ist...
Schreibe ich denn das jetzt am besten?
Nicht
Kompetenz.
Die versuchen, Kompetenz auszustrahlen.
Sie strahlen aber keine Kompetenz aus.
Die Leute strahlen
gespielte Kompetenz aus. So gewollte
Kompetenz.
Das fällt euch, wenn ihr da mal drauf achtet,
das wird euch bei allen diesen Coaching-Videos
auffallen und auch bei diesen
ganzen Videos. Ihr kennt doch noch früher
die Videos, die für YouTube kamen.
Porsche, irgendwas,
die Geldscheine aus dem Fenster.
Das sind alles...
Nein, nein, nein, das meine ich nicht.
Dass es im Endeffekt Scam ist, da sind wir uns glaube ich
alle einig.
Vielleicht doch das eine oder andere nicht Scam.
Die Ausstrahlung der Leute,
die Ausstrahlung dieser Leute ist immer so
gespielte Kompetenz.
Hochstapler, ja genau.
Aber ich finde so gespielte Kompetenz
trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Versucht geschauspielerte Kompetenz.
Blender, ja genau, sowas.
Die strahlen, also du merkst
richtig, dass sie geübt haben,
Kompetenz auszustrahlen.
Aber sie strahlen keine Kompetenz aus,
sie strahlen gespielte Kompetenz aus.
Und
ich finde,
das ist so eines dieser Sachen,
das haben die alle so gemeinsam.
Gut, man mag ja durchaus
den einen oder anderen geben, die Kompetenz
nicht nur spielen, sondern wirklich kompetent sind.
Aber dann bestimmt nicht, weil sie irgendwelchen
Trades blind aus irgendeiner Telegram-Gruppe folgen.
Ich kenne auch Trader.
Wie gesagt, ich hab über 10 Jahre bei einer Bank,
aber ich arbeite auch, ich kenne auch Trader.
Und sie sind bestimmt nicht kacke, sonst wären sie
wahrscheinlich keine Trader mehr.
Ich sag nicht, dass es keine
erfolgreichen Trader geben kann.
Aber die Leute, die diese Videos
präsentieren, die wirken
immer so gespielt kompetent.
So als hätte man
sich ein Online-Rhetorik-Video angeguckt,
wie strahle ich Kompetenz
aus? Und so wirkt das
immer. Nicht wirklich kompetent,
sondern so gespielt kompetent.
Und
ich glaube, eine weitere
Sache, die
kann ich jetzt nicht
belegen,
weil ich persönlich das noch
nicht erlebt habe und ich auch gar keinen Bock
drauf habe, aber
ich kenne anderweitig
Leute, die gerne
mal mehr erzählen, als eigentlich dahinter
ist. Und eins, was diesen Leuten
alle gemein ist, wenn man sie
darauf anspricht, dann rasten
die komplett aus. Und genauso
schätze ich diese ganzen Coaching-Leute auch ein.
Die ganzen Coaching-Leute,
die so gespielt kompetent sind,
wenn du die mal
call out, also wenn du denen mal sagen würdest,
ey, dann zeig doch mal, wie kompetent
du bist. Wisst ihr, was die einzige
Antwort ist, die diesen Leuten einfällt?
Das ist nicht quasi, das zu untermauern,
dass man kompetent ist, sondern
denjenigen, der das in Frage stellt, aufs Übelste
zu beleidigen.
Kennt ihr so Typen von Leuten, die gerne
das Blaue vom Himmel runter erzählen, dass
sie die geilsten auf der Welt sind?
Und wenn du ihnen dann sagst, hey, guck mal,
ich glaub das nicht,
erzähl doch mal ein bisschen genauer,
dass sie dann nicht dich überzeugen können,
sondern dich einfach nur noch beleidigen können.
Da kommt dann sowas als
Antwort. Ich kann es mir bei solchen
Leuten richtig gut vorstellen.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt so diesen 0815
Aktientrader-Dude, der so möchtegern
kompetent ist und ihr sagt, ja dann
erzähl doch mal, was sind denn hier so deine
Verdienste, was hast du denn
schon alles gemacht und wie hat sich das so
entwickelt? Und
dann fühlen die sich übelst angegriffen.
Jemand, der wirklich kompetent ist,
der schafft es auch,
dich zu überzeugen davon, dass er kompetent
ist mit Kompetenz. Und nicht
nur mit, wir sagen, dass wir kompetent
sind, sondern indem er dich überzeugt mit seinen
Ausgaben und mit seinem Fachwissen
und mit seinen Aussagen dazu.
Aber wenn du solche Leute darauf ansprichst,
dann zeig doch mal, dann kommt dann als
Antwort nur so was in der
Richtung wie, so alter, wer bist
du denn? Du bist voll unbedeutend.
Wer bist du denn? Halt's
Maul, du hast keine Ahnung. Ich ficke
deine Mutter.
Ja, also, so was
kriegst du dann eher als Antwort. Nicht so die Überzeug...
Nicht, dass man überzeugt
wird mit Kompetenz, sondern einfach,
dass die Leute sich übelst angegriffen und beleidigt fühlen.
Und spätestens ab dem Punkt weißt du, dass die eigentlich
nur schwätzen. Ob's in dem Fall
jetzt so ist, keine Ahnung.
Aber solche Typen, Menschen,
sind halt so drauf.
Auch wenn man versteht, was ich meine.
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn ich euch
jetzt erzählen würde, Leute, ich kann 15
Programmiersprachen, ich kann das, ich kann
jenes, ich kann hier und das.
Und dann wird einer sagen, Max,
dann mach doch mal ein Hello World in Ruby.
Und ich sag dann nicht, ja,
hier, easy, äh, putz,
äh, dings hier, putz,
Hello World, sondern
ich sag dann, alter, du Kackspast,
wer bist du denn, dass du hier sowas fragst, überhaupt
im Chat, ich bann dich jetzt hier,
du unbedeutender, was auch immer.
Ja?
Also, würdet ihr mir dann glauben, dass ich
wirklich kompetent bin?
Nee, oder? Ihr würdet auch eher davon ausgehen,
okay, der hat mir Scheiße erzählt, warum zeigt das nicht einfach,
wenn er es doch so gut kann?
Das ist halt das Problem.
Da ist halt wahrscheinlich nichts dahinter.
So, gucken wir das Video
weiter, sonst dauert das noch drei Stunden.
Und ich meine, Charts auf Monitor
anmachen und drauf deuten, kann ja nur wirklich jeder.
Noch endlich in die Gruppe. Inhaltlich
erfährt man hier überhaupt nichts, außer
natürlich, dass die Leute in der VIP-Gruppe
Inhaltlich erfährt man, dass man das
Gewinner-High-Performer-Crying-Set-Mindset
braucht wahrscheinlich. Mega fett Cash machen.
Haben wir ja auch schon gesehen in der
Insta-Story. Nicht.
Jetzt kommt doch endlich in die Scheiß-Gruppe.
Am 22. Juni schreibt er zum Beispiel,
die ersten vier Leute, die sich bei ihm melden,
kommen kostenlos in die VIP-Gruppe.
Bruder, das ist immer kostenlos. Er sagt das
jedes Mal. Am 23. Juni
wird einfach die allererste Nachricht aus der Gruppe
vom 19. Juni nochmal gepostet.
Einfach, ja, komm hier, rein damit.
Und immer wieder postet er auch Videos und Sprachnachrichten
von sich selber, wo er eigentlich
immer genau... By the way,
es ist ja streng genommen nicht Apourettes
Abzock-Gruppe, oder?
Es ist Lukas' Abzock-Gruppe,
für die Apourette Werbung gemacht hat
und wahrscheinlich einen kostenlosen Dubai-Urlaub
ein bisschen Kohle dafür spendiert bekommen hat.
Aber trotzdem kann man
natürlich in Frage stellen, warum Apourette für sowas
Werbung macht. Vermutlich braucht er
schlicht und ergreifend Geld.
Könnte ich mir vorstellen.
Der Insi-Modus, der ist bestimmt nicht so angenehm.
Das gleiche erzähle.
Es ist alles kostenlos.
Ich bin wirklich der Einzige, der das genau so
anbietet. Einmal sagt er in einem Video
aber auch das hier. Ich hatte damals ein riesen
Signal-Service, wo ich Leuten für 50 Euro
im Monat meine Trade-Idee verkauft habe.
Aber mittlerweile, es sind fünfeinhalb
Jahre vergangen, seitdem ich im Markt aktiv bin.
Warum müssen wir
uns jetzt eigentlich oben ohne
angucken, wie er was über Trading erzählt?
Und was hat er in der Hand?
Eine Zigarre oder sowas.
Natürlich eine teure Zigarre, ist klar.
Das ist immer die gleiche Masche.
Es ist immer die gleiche, seit Jahren schon.
Und soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Die Masche
ist nicht nur seit Jahren die gleiche.
Die Masche ist seit Jahrzehnten die gleiche.
Nur, dass es jetzt halt seit ein paar Jahren
übers Internet gemacht wird. Ich habe euch doch
erzählt, mein Vater, also
wenn es darum geht,
ich kenne Leute
persönlich ziemlich gut, die andere Leute
jahrelang gescammt haben.
Mein Vater hatte auch einen Scambusiness früher.
Zwar anderweitig,
es ging zwar nicht um
Finanzberatung,
aber er hat auch die Leute krass gescammt.
Und hat damit extrem
viel Kohle gemacht.
Und
die Masche,
das ist alles immer der gleiche Shit.
Du musst einfach nur
möglichst kompetent den Leuten das erzählen,
was sie hören wollen. Fertig.
Das ist bei den ganzen Scams immer das gleiche.
Du musst so wirken, als weißt du,
wovon du sprichst,
und dann den Leuten das erzählen,
was sie hören wollen.
Und wenn die Leute hören wollen,
also wenn die Zielgruppe ist,
wie kann ich
schnell reich werden, ohne großartigen
Einsatz?
Wer will das nicht?
Und die Leute dann noch so blöd sind dran glauben,
zack, hast du wieder welche.
Also die Story von meinem Vater habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt.
Mein Vater hat Leute gescammt,
zwar nicht mit Finanzzeug,
sondern
mit einer Partnervermittlung
für ältere Leute.
Was bedeutet gescammt?
Beschissen.
Mein Vater hat
Leute gescammt mit einer Partnervermittlung
für ältere Leute.
Und der hat das im Prinzip auf die gleiche Art und
Weise gemacht.
Da kam dann Oma Erna hin,
60, 65 Jahren,
und hat gesagt, oh, mein Mann ist gestorben vor
10 Jahren und ich würde mir doch schon mal wieder jemand
wünschen, mit dem ich mich gut verstehe
und mit dem es alles so gut läuft.
Die sind dann da hingegangen
und haben das halt
erzählt, was sie sich so wünschen.
Und da ist mein Vater halt hin, oder die Verkäufer dort
halt hin und haben gesagt, jawohl,
Frau Müller, wir haben genau die
richtigen Kandidaten für Sie
und wunderbar, wir werden das alles für Sie
regeln. Sie müssen natürlich einen
Vertrag,
warum nicht? Ich hab das schon 500
Mal oder so erzählt, zumindest.
So, hier,
das ist übrigens, das ist nicht
strafrechtlich relevant, weil das war
vor Gericht und so alles, das ist alles schon durch.
Und
natürlich musste die dafür dann
einen Vertrag unterschreiben.
So nach dem Motto, ja, hier,
3.000 Mark waren
das wahrscheinlich oder sowas noch, damals hier,
damit wir sie quasi in unserer
Vermittlungsding aufnehmen können.
Und dann ging's weiter.
Dann ging's weiter.
Die
wurden, die haben dann auch Leute
vermittelt, den, ich nenn's mal den Omas,
ja, denen haben die auch Leute vermittelt.
Nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass sie nicht wirklich Leute vermittelt
haben. Die hatten so einen Pool
aus, ja, etwas älteren,
aber, sagen wir mal, gut
aussehenden und netten Herren,
so, was weiß ich, 10 verschiedene,
5-10 verschiedene. Und die haben
dann einfach zu den Omas
immer diese Leute heimgeschickt.
Immer die gleichen Leute
zu den unterschiedlichen Omas
heim. Und die haben denen
halt schöne Augen gemacht, so, oh,
Frau Müller, wir sind
seelenverwandt, so, ach, keine Ahnung, was
sie denen erzählt haben.
Und dementsprechend hat die
halt Monat für Monat
Vermittlungsgebühren und Sachen abgedrückt.
Und mein Vater hat damit
wahnsinnig viel Geld gemacht.
Und das Geile ist,
jetzt haltet euch mal fest,
das Geile ist, das ist irgendwann
auch vor Gericht gelandet.
Suspicious User, warum ist das
Suspicious User? Also,
Leani,
ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht, aus irgendwelchen
Gründen wurde deine
Nachricht gerade
gefleckt.
Ja, keine Ahnung, warum.
Ey, das sind, Leute, das war
irgendwie 1900, frag mich nicht,
1990 rum oder sowas.
Ja, noch ein bisschen früher sogar.
Das ist ewig her, zu Zeiten, wo es
noch keine Partnervermittlung im Internet gab.
Und, natürlich,
ja, aber, das,
das würde ich den Omas
gar nicht mal unbedingt vorwerfen.
Das ist wie die Leute, die in irgendwelche komischen
WhatsApp-Gruppen heute rein
joinen, ja, und denken, sie werden reich.
Liegt das
nicht auf, wenn irgendwann, warum, die kennen
sich doch nicht. Die kennen sich doch nicht.
Du bist der Hacker, man, nice.
Schön, dass du da bist.
Ähm, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Die kennen sich doch nicht. So,
und jetzt kommt aber, jetzt kommt der Hit.
Wenn ihr denkt, dass es illegal,
Nido, danke für den Sub, wenn ihr jetzt denkt, dass es illegal
wäre oder so, die
erzählen, das sind doch nicht ihre Freundinnen.
Ach so, du meinst, die Freundinnen gehen
dahin, ja. Ne, das ist, also,
es ist in der Form nie aufgeflogen.
Und das ist dann irgendwann auch vor Gericht gelandet.
So, und jetzt haltet euch mal fest. Man würde sich jetzt
auch denken, alter, klarer Scam
und sowas.
Aber, mein Vater ist freigesprochen
geworden. Weil,
und jetzt kommt's,
die Leute haben das freiwillig
gemacht. Und die Leute haben
diesen Vertrag komplett freiwillig
unterschrieben. Und in diesem Vertrag
stand genau drin, was die Firma von
meinem Vater macht.
Die haben das schlicht und ergreifend
verstanden, nicht richtig gelesen.
Und haben sich noch gefreut,
3000 Euro abdrücken zu dürfen, immer mal wieder.
Weil ja nette Herren vorbeigeschickt
wurden. Und es muss wohl
so gewesen sein, dass der Richter,
das ist jetzt Story von meinem Vater, ich hab
keine Ahnung, ob das wirklich stimmt, ja, aber
das glaube ich ihm.
Es muss wohl so gewesen sein,
dass bei diesem Gerichtsverfahren der Richter
einen der älteren
Damen gefragt hat,
warum haben sie das denn unterschrieben?
Und die hat
dann halt wohl geantwortet, ihr war nicht klar,
was sie da eigentlich genau unterschreibt.
Aber da kann ja mein Vater nix für.
Also wie gesagt, das Ganze
ist vor Gericht gelandet, mein Vater ist freigesprochen
geworden.
Das war quasi
ganz offiziell kein Betrug.
Und
sie haben ihn dann zwar
für andere Sachen verknackt,
das hab ich euch ja anderweitig schon mal erzählt,
beziehungsweise, naja,
verknackt ist das falsche Wort, der saß halt
in Untersuchungshaft
und wurde dann auch verurteilt,
aber das war wegen was anderem, das war nicht
wegen dem Scam
an den Omas.
Und insofern könnte man eigentlich
sagen, alles richtig gemacht,
auch wenn ich es trotzdem verwerflich finde.
Also rein rechtlich gesehen, alles richtig
gemacht, insgesamt doch hochgradig
fragwürdig, was er da getrieben hat.
Und er hat extrem viel
Kohle damit gemacht.
Deswegen ja,
nochmal so als, deswegen
finde ich es ja heute
rückblickend nochmal
extra verwerflich, dass er meiner Mutter auch
am Anfang oder später auch keinen Unterhalt
bezahlen wollte.
Haben die Männer Geld bekommen? Klar.
Klar. Die waren quasi so
halb Angestellte davon, glaube ich.
Weiß nicht, wie das genau gelaufen ist.
Weil, als ich meine Mutter
und meinen Vater getrennt habe, da war der gerade
richtig dick in diesem Partnervermittlungs-Business
und hat massig Geld verdient.
Und irgendwann
hat er halt gesagt, er kann
keinen Unterhalt bezahlen, weil er braucht
mindestens 10.000 Mark im
Monat für sich, sonst kann er nicht leben.
Und erst, was er übrig, ihr könnt euch
überlegen, 1990 rum waren 10.000 Mark
im Monat verdammt viel Geld.
Und er musste ja auch noch seine Angestellten bezahlen
und alles. Musst dir mal vorstellen,
das sagst du deiner Ex-Frau mit dem Kind
so nach dem Motto, also, ich brauche erst mal
10.000 Mark
im Monat für mich. Wenn ich dann da drüber was übrig
habe, kann ich euch vielleicht auch ein bisschen was abgeben.
Was eines der Gründe ist, warum
ich vielleicht nicht allzu gut auf meinen Vater zu sprechen bin.
Aber der hat richtig
fett Kohle gemacht mit dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Ja, also,
ihr seht, die Scam
Mechanismen
und Scam
diese Arten
von Scam, die sind seit Jahrzehnten
ähnlich. Du musst
einfach nur möglichst überzeugend
Leuten das erzählen, was sie hören wollen.
Und so funktionieren diese ganzen Scam-Gruppen hier auch.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns den aber weiter
oben ohne an, was er uns wieder für krasse Trading-Tipps
gibt.
Warum hat er da eine Gruppe?
Also, er macht
das alles nur um...
bloß von ihm.
Auf diese 50 Euro von uns zu verzichten.
Dann erzählt er uns, dass er sich die Augen
hat lasern lassen, natürlich nur mit
dem Profit vom Trading.
Na klar. Und hey, auch ApoRed kommt
in seinem Video immer vor.
Hat mich wirklich sehr
gefreut, dass wir ihn auch mal da gesehen haben.
Aber ich hab das Gefühl, der Lukas ist ein seriöser
Boy. Er weiß, auf dem Markt ist viel
Bullshit, aber er, er ist
real. Was auffällt ist, dass er erstaunlich
oft kein T-Shirt anhat,
aber sehr oft Zigarre raucht.
Ja, das ist halt der krasse
Lifestyle. 15 Minuten am Tag
traden, easy money, easy Millionen
und nix dafür machen. Das ist ja auch
das, was die Leute hören wollen.
Das ist das, was die Leute hören wollen.
Also Leute, die das ansprechen sollen, genau
das wollen die hören. Ohne Aufwand
fette Kohle machen.
Aber immer wieder musste ich an diese
VIP-Gruppe denken und fand es irgendwie komisch.
Diese mysteriösen Leute,
diese Special-Leute, viel weiter
oben als wir. Aber fallen da so
viele drauf rein, dass die immer Urlaubsvideos posten
können? Naja, also ich denke
schon, dass da immer noch genug Leute drauf reinfallen.
Dass dieser Lifestyle
stimmt, weiß man ja gar nicht.
Es gab ja schon zig Videos dazu,
so nach dem Motto von gefälschter
Uhrensammlung bis mal kurz
einen Kurztrip irgendwohin gemietet, um Videos
aufzunehmen. Da ist ja immer viel mehr Schein
als Sein. Aber dass der Typ in
Dubai wohnt, kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Ich meine,
das ist bestimmt auch steuerlich
besser als in Deutschland.
Ja, und die leihen
sich teilweise die Autos nur aus, die Uhren nur
aus. Da ist ganz
viel Fake
und
ja, mehr
Schein als Sein dahinter.
Ja, tu dir keinen Zwang an.
Also,
naja, okay, weiter.
Am 8. Juli
schreibt er zum Beispiel, es gibt nur noch 22
Plätze in der Gruppe. Danach wird die Gruppe
zugemacht. Okay, wow, äh, jetzt
wird's knapp. Ein paar Nachrichten später schreibt er,
dass nur noch 5 Leute rein können.
Am 9. Juli schreibt er auch,
Ja, es hat keiner gejoint.
Oder, oder,
soll das etwa bedeuten, die letzte Nachricht war
nicht echt? Die letzte Nachricht
war gelogen? Das kann nicht sein. Das glaube ich nicht.
Und am 10. Juli können auch
nur noch 5 Leute rein.
Naja, also irgendwie komisch, oder?
Und auch am 10. Juli erzählt er uns, dass in der Gruppe
aktuell 289 Menschen sind
und bei 300 macht er die Gruppe zu,
dann kostet es, wenn man da rein möchte.
So, Leute, ihr seht hier die VIP-Gruppe.
Wir haben fast 300. Okay, nice.
So, der erste Trade.
300 Member, bei 300 mach ich zu,
Leute, dann kostet der Scheiß, ja?
Warum kostet es dann, ja? Warum dürfen nicht
301 Menschen in die Gruppe?
Wo ist der Unterschied? Ich dachte, das ist die ganze Zeit
kostenlos. Das ist zu krass. Naja,
dann kommt am 12. Juli die Meldung, die Gruppe
ist zu. Leute, ich habe jetzt erst mal
die Gruppe zugemacht. Scheiße,
jetzt habe ich es verpasst. Ich wollte doch rein.
Aber, Jack, wait.
Was haben wir denn da? Ein paar Nachrichten später.
5 Leute können noch rein.
Ja, das liegt daran, wie der Chat gesagt hatte,
die sind jetzt reich genug, die 5
Leute, und sind aus der Gruppe wieder raus.
Deswegen können jetzt 5 neue Leute rein.
Die haben jetzt ihr Easy Money gemacht
und sind jetzt so nett und machen einfach 5 weiteren
Platz. Ist doch logisch.
Ja, das ist aber merkwürdig. Irgendwie
fühlt sich das komisch an.
Nur noch 5 Plätze? Da muss man sich
aber... Ja, es ist einfach alles ganz nette Leute.
Melden. Also habe ich
das gemacht und gewartet, dass er mich
endlich in die Gruppe holt. Schließlich möchte ich doch
die geilen, geilen Trades mitbekommen.
Damit auch ich Multimillionär werden kann.
Und dann habe ich gewartet und gewartet
und gewartet und endlich
hat er sich... Kaiser war in der
VIP-Gruppe. Ich habe das Video vorhin
in der YouTube-Übersicht
gesehen.
Bro, du kannst rein.
Ey, was ein Zufall. Unter den letzten
5 Leuten, die noch reingepasst haben. Sonst wäre
die Gruppe bestimmt voll gewesen. Was?
Ach, es werden immer noch Leute aufgenommen.
Das ist ja komisch. Und wenn man dann
in diesem Stadium angelangt ist, erfährt man
erstmal, wie der Hase da eigentlich läuft.
Natürlich kommt man nicht einfach so rein. Nein, man muss
ein paar Bedingungen erfüllen. Und zwar muss man
auf der Website T4Trade ein
Konto eröffnen. Ah, Moment.
Die kommen mir bekannt vor.
T4Trade.
Mir ist fast
so, als hätte ich die schon mal
im Zusammenhang mit so genau dem gleichen
Scam
in anderem Zusammenhang mal
gesehen. Die Uhr sieht
tatsächlich aus wie vom nigerianischen
Prinz in der E-Mail. Ja.
Agile Enjoyer.
Sag mal, was hast du eigentlich auf
Agile Enjoyer... Was hast du eigentlich
auf Twitch angestellt in der Vergangenheit?
Weil jeder
deiner Nachrichten wird mir geflaggt
als suspicious user.
Du musst ja schon mal irgendwas
getrieben haben. Ich gucke
jetzt mal in die Chat History. Was ist
da so? Timeout. Du wurdest timeoutet.
Warum wurdest du timeoutet?
Weil du sehr merkwürdige
Sachen geschrieben hast.
Okay.
Ja, aber jetzt nichts super
Schlimmes. Du hast komische
Sachen, aber nichts super Schlimmes.
Lass mal weiter gucken.
100 Euro einzahlen. Und zwar nur.
Er wiederholt das. Nur.
Über diesen einen bestimmten Link.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil es
irgendein Affiliate Link von ihm ist.
Und zwar nur. Er wiederholt das.
Nur. Über diesen...
Ich empfehle 1000 Euro plus. Ja, selbstverständlich
empfiehlt er das.
Schick mir einen Screenshot, wenn die
Einzahlung erfolgt und dann
packe ich dich sofort in die Gruppe rein.
Okay.
Ja.
Okay. Gut, es ist ja nett,
dass er auf die 50 Euro im Monat verzichtet.
Sieht man ja,
wie selbstlos das Ganze ist.
Diesen einen bestimmten...
T4 Trade.
Okay, wir müssen uns mal kurz...
Okay, nice.
Das wirkt schon äußerst
vertrauenserweckend, würde ich
sagen, oder?
Also,
sofort rein, ja?
Wirkt ja alles extrem
seriös.
Gag B.
Beste Comments.
Ja gut, 15...
Leute, die Comments
schreiben die doch erst nach dem
Video jetzt, oder?
Gag B.
Der Allerechte hat gesagt, ich mache
5k im Monat. Habe ich auch, aber
Minus.
Wenn der Insi-Hase...
Okay, jetzt wissen wir, wo die Leute herkommen.
Okay, jetzt ist klar, wo die Leute herkommen
in den Comments, ja?
Aber es gibt auch noch ein paar ältere, ältere,
sagen wir mal, realere Bewertungen.
I'm so angry, big scam.
Stay away, guys.
Gibt das nicht
noch irgendwie... Trustpilot! Okay,
Trustpilot. Zeig mal her.
3,7?
Habe ich schon Schlimmeres gesehen?
Wer ist DMO? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich google jetzt auch nicht danach.
Es ist immer ein bisschen schwierig hier,
je nachdem, was da herkommt.
Okay, lasst uns mal die 5-Sterne-Bewertung angucken.
Die sind bestimmt alle legit.
Kann man das auch
sortieren nach auf Deutsch?
Nee, oder?
Ach so, gibt's in
allen Sprachen.
Bestimmt...
Bestimmt äußerst, äußerst
legit, diese Bewertung. Okay, 5-Star-Bewertung.
Why I feel safe.
Okay.
Company is...
Ja, klar. Das ist
bestimmt alles legit, die ganzen Comments
hier.
Ja, ja.
Alles klar. Wollen wir wetten,
dass die nur auf positive Comments
antworten und nicht auf negative?
Es ist auch schon verdächtig, ja?
Es ist verdächtig, dass es
so viele 5- und 4-Stars gibt,
aber auch so viele 1-Stars.
Das ist eine komische Verteilung.
Normalerweise sollte die Verteilung
exakt umgedreht sein.
Also wenn das wirklich
so bei 3,7 liegt,
dann sollte die normale Verteilung eigentlich eher
so sein und nicht so.
Wisst ihr, wie ich mein?
Also eigentlich sollte es dann wenige 1-Star,
wenige 5-Star geben und halt viele
4-, 3- und 2-Star,
dass man auf 3,7 kommt, aber die kommen ja auf 3,7.
Der statistische
Hase ist am Start, genau.
Das ist schon
sehr verdächtig, ja?
Also gucken wir uns mal 1-Star an.
Oh, die antworten auch.
Please note, that this review has not
ehm, das ist bestimmt
dann fake, ja.
Naja, egal. Es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt,
was, äh, lasst uns mal was anderes gucken.
TWSI, T for Trade,
Sitz, wo sind die?
Oder hier,
Impressum, Impressum, was soll
hier? Ach, was suche ich denn da am besten?
Ah, sie schälen, okay.
Finde ich jetzt aber nicht, ob die wirklich
auf, ich will nicht auf die Seite drauf,
ehrlich gesagt. Okay, wir gehen, Moment,
wir gehen das in einem anonymen Tab unter Linux.
Man weiß ja nie, wo man da rauskommt.
Okay, wo, wo
sitzen die denn?
Lasst uns
grad mal gucken. Ja, ja, trotzdem erfahren.
Äh,
haben die irgendwas, wo
die sitzen?
Richtlinien, Datenschutz, Richtlinie,
ja, wir erlauben alles.
Hmm.
Risikohinweis?
Aha, aha, okay.
Wo sitzen die denn?
Kriegt man das irgendwo raus?
Über uns.
Über uns?
Ja, keine
Stockfotos. Hier.
Äh, T for Trade,
mit der eingetragenen Adresse
F20, first floor,
in, äh, sie schälen.
Nice.
Nee, da guckt man sich, sie schälen.
Okay, top.
Das ist ja schon, also wenn das, wenn das
nicht ultra seriös ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Link. Darauf kommen wir nochmal
gleich zu sprechen. Warum denn bloß?
T for Trade. Naja, warum bloß? Weil er wahrscheinlich
Geld daran verdient, wenn sich einer über seinen RefLink anmeldet.
Tradingseite, mit der er offensichtlich
arbeitet und mit der auch alle seine
Leute in der WhatsApp-Gruppe arbeiten sollen.
Telegram-Gruppe, ja, Entschuldigung. Und wenn man sich das Ganze
mal genauer anguckt und wissen möchte, was dahinter
steckt, sieht man, dass T for Trade
Haben die ein starkes TLS-Zertifikat
bekommen? Das gucken wir jetzt mal, aber
wahrscheinlich. Ich mein, es ist ja überhaupt
kein Problem, echte, echte
echte SSL-Zertifikate
zu bekommen, wenn man eine Domain besitzt.
Die haben bestimmt auch Let's Encrypt,
hä? Ah nee, okay.
Naja, die haben die Standard,
kein Ding, also.
SSL-Zertifikate zu bekommen, heißt ja nix.
Es bedeutet ja nur, du bist auch wirklich
derjenige, der du
vorgibst zu sein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du seriös bist oder nicht.
Woher hast du denn das tolle Desktop-Hintergrund-Bild?
Hier. Gehst du auf GitHub?
Hier hast du die alle. Das ist nicht nur eins,
das ist nicht nur eins, du hast für jede,
also Lukas, du hast hier für jede Tageszeit
ein passendes, guck.
Bald, bald
würde ich sagen, gehen wir auch über
zu PPo Mittagessen,
so in der Richtung hier.
Gurkenschurke,
ja, da war irgendwas.
Das ist das gleiche wie mit CS-Go
Skin-Seiten und sowas, wo teilweise auch
übelst gescammt wird. Könnte von ausgehen, es schenkt
euch nirgendwo irgendjemand was.
Und insofern,
wenn euch das einer verspricht, ist das
meistens ein Scam.
Sie schellen, ja, da haben wir auch gerade rausgekickt.
In diesem seriösen Gebäude, direkt
neben diesem seriösen Spielcasino.
Ich finde das vollkommen
legit. Da kennen sie sich
wenigstens mit Geld aus. Ich sollte sofort alles
hinüberweisen. Sieht doch vertrauenserweckend aus,
oder? Also, falls ihr doch mal irgendwie
Probleme mit dieser Firma bekommen solltet,
viel Spaß, von da euer Geld zurückzubekommen.
Wenn man sich dazu die Bewertungen bei Trustpilot
mal anguckt, sieht man, 3,9
klingt jetzt erstmal gar nicht so scheiße.
Allerdings klingen alle deutschen Bewertungen
schon sehr nach Fake.
Zum Beispiel werden in allen Bewertungen...
Ich habe überhaupt keine deutschen Bewertungen gefunden gerade.
Kann es sein, dass man... Aber man kann die bestimmt nicht löschen lassen.
... die engen Spreads
positiv hervorgehoben. Ah, natürlich,
das ist mir natürlich sehr wichtig, diese
engen Spreads, ja. Macht Trustpilot
Auto Translation oder sowas?
Auch Wörter wie
wettbewerbsfähig oder leistungsstark...
Ne, ich habe keine 5-Star-Deutschen Bewertungen gefunden.
Vielleicht war das einfach nur
irgendeine Auto... Ne, also, habe ich ja gerade
geguckt, gab es nicht.
Was war denn das hier gerade für
ein Overlay? Habt ihr das gerade gesehen?
Skip to Content? Wo kam denn das her?
Hackermans auf meine
Linux-Kiste, Leute! MonkaS!
Das habe ich zu Content geskippt und da ist nichts
passiert. Siehste, deswegen
schreibe ich so Sachen nur unter Linux auf.
... die niemand einfach
so in so einer Bewertung schreiben würde, werden doch
sehr oft wiederholt und klingen schon sehr geskriptet.
Gleichzeitig hat diese Plattform
aber auch sehr viele Einsterne-Bewertungen,
die da verwarnen, diese Plattform zu benutzen,
weil sie auch von Scammern benutzt wird.
Manche Scammer werden sogar direkt namentlich
genannt, die das genau mit der gleichen Masche gemacht haben.
Sobald du dich über den bestimmten Link
einer Person anmeldest, wird diese Person
an allen Investments, die du tust, beteiligt,
auch wenn du Verlust machst. Die müssen ihre
heftigen Trading-Tipps also gar nicht kostenpflichtig
machen, weil die eh, egal
was du machst, dabei mitverdienen.
Und diese Scammer, die in diesen Bewertungen...
IP-Leak! Oh nein! Wo habe ich die IP geleakt?
Hier?
Localhost oder was habe ich geleakt? MonkaS!
Shit!
IP-Leak, Leute!
...genannt werden, leben jetzt auch in Dubai.
Das ist aber irgendwie alles ganz schön
komisch und das erklärt auch, warum man unbedingt
diesen einen bestimmten Link nutzen sollte
und mindestens 300 Euro einzahlen muss.
Spoiler! Weniger geht nicht.
Warum auch immer. Es gab keine Begründung.
Vielleicht weil der Lukas dann einfach zu wenig
daran verdient, ne? Aber mehr geht natürlich, klar.
Damit ich dann überhaupt in die VIP-Gruppe komme,
sollte ich dann das Konto eröffnen, das Geld...
Lasst uns mal just for fun, ich will
das jetzt einfach nur mal ausprobieren.
Ähm...
Lasst uns doch mal kurz gucken,
auf was das
T4Trade, auf was
denn ihre Webseite basiert.
ViewPageSource.
WordPress.
Ah, daher kam das
SkipToContent.
WordPress. Na dann.
Okay, dann ist das irgendein gekauftes
Webhosting, da ist dann wahrscheinlich auch
nix... Was?
Moment.
Lasst uns mal kurz checken.
Moin, BlackHD19.
Lasst uns mal kurz gucken.
Vielleicht haben wir offene SSH-Ports oder sowas.
Oh nee, haben die etwa irgendeine
Nmap-Protection oder sowas?
Ich sehe es hier schon.
What the fuck? Nee, das kann nicht
sein.
Das kann nicht sein.
Das glaube ich ja nicht, dass das alles
offen ist dort.
Die haben irgendwas, was
Nmap verwirrt.
Ich meine, vielleicht?
Wait a minute.
Der Port
ist wirklich offen? What?
Ähm...
Das ist doch bestimmt
Absicht, oder?
Witzig. Nun gut.
Genug mit dem.
Ja, das kann natürlich sein.
Chatge, das kann natürlich wirklich
sein. Warum auch immer.
Was sie davon haben. Weiß ja nicht.
Hack...
Hackermens verwirren.
Ja, aber gucken wir mal das Video fertig.
Geld einzahlen und dann, wenn das
Geld eingegangen ist, ihm ein Foto davon als
Beweis schicken, dann wäre ich reingekommen.
Ich hab mal darauf verzichtet, 300 Euro
sind mir dann doch ein bisschen zu teuer.
Irgendwie hab ich das Gefühl, ich krieg das Geld nicht wieder.
Aber wenn man mal überlegt, dass mindestens
300 Leute in der WhatsApp-Gruppe sind,
kommt da bei mindestens 300 Euro
pro Person schon einiges zusammen.
Und ich find's so komisch, dass immer noch heutzutage
so viele Menschen auf so eine Masche reinfallen.
Das wundert
mich auch. Das ist wirklich nichts
Neues. Was ich auch komisch finde bei
allen Instagram-Stories, wo guckt
ApoRed hin? Weil das jedes Mal so aussieht,
als würde er einfach an der Kamera vorbeigucken,
weil dahinter jemand steht, der ihm Anweisungen gibt.
Eigentlich. Ja.
Durchaus möglich.
Müsste doch ein Influencer mit
jahrelanger Erfahrung in der Lage sein,
in eine Kameralinse zu gucken. Das ist ja nicht
so kompliziert, ja? Auge, Kameralinse,
rein. Außer
jemand steht hinter der Kamera
mit großen Schildern, mit
den Sachen, die ApoRed dann vorlesen soll.
Damit er halt seinen Text nicht vergisst, ne?
Komisch. Ich glaube, wenn das
wirklich stimmt, wäre das mit das Witzigste,
was ich jemals in meinem Leben gesehen habe.
Ich hoffe, vielleicht auf irgendeiner
Festplatte von Mimi taucht noch irgendwelches Material
dazu auf. Wenn ja, sagt mir auf jeden Fall Bescheid, Leute.
Diese ganze Aktion wirkt
so unfassbar random. Wir haben lange nichts
mehr von ihm gehört. Insolvenz,
in Deutschland irgendwie schwierig. Insi-Modus.
Plötzlich in Dubai, plötzlich diese sehr
erfolgreiche Trading-Gruppe. Und was ich bei dieser
ganzen Aktion nicht verstehe, solche Gruppen
sind ja nichts Neues. Die gibt's ja schon seit Jahren.
Und die Leute wissen eigentlich schon seit Jahren.
Das verstehe ich auch nicht. Aber wie gesagt,
ich habe euch das ja vorhin versucht zu erklären,
dass diese Masche,
wir erzählen den Leuten halt, was sie hören
wollen,
das klappt schon ewig.
Insofern, warum sollte das
im Internet irgendwie nicht mehr klappen?
Und es klappt seit Jahren schon. Also,
machen die weiter, bis es irgendwann nicht mehr klappt.
Dass das kompletter Trash ist. Wir erinnern
uns alle an diese wunderbaren Videos hier.
Porsche Cayman S, Jungs!
Das Prinzip hier
ist genau das gleiche.
Komm in die Gruppe, es ist unverbindlich,
kostenlos. Wir zeigen dir, wie Trading
geht. Guck, wie erfolgreich die anderen Leute
geworden sind. Hinter all diesen Punkten...
Du brauchst einfach... Leute, du brauchst
keine Ahnung, keine Expertise,
keine Kompetenz. Das Einzige,
was du brauchst, ist, du brauchst
das Grindset, Mindset, High-Performer...
...Performance...
Mindset. Ja?
Das ist alles, was du brauchst. Rechts brauchst du nicht.
Genau wie damals kann man jetzt auch einen Haken machen.
Das sollte alles bekannt sein. Wer
fällt im Jahr 2023 darauf noch rein?
Ach ja, äh, hat ja über 5000
Mitglieder der Kanal. Ja, ich kann
mich täuschen, ne? Aber eigentlich ist
das doch eine altbekannte Masche. Die Masche,
dass Leute da Geld einzahlen und wahrscheinlich
ihr Geld nicht mehr wiederbekommen. Und die
Betreiber davon leben in irgendwelchen Luxusländern
wie Dubai und protzen mit teuren Autos,
Hotels und schicken Essen. Oder
stehen auch wie Lukas nachdenklich im
Wüstensand. Vielleicht liegt aber auch das
Geheimnis in solchen... Ach, daher hat er die
Eingebung für seine Trades.
Ich dieb in Gedanken wie
Shisha plus Laptop gleich
Money.
Geil.
Ja, so geht's.
Das müsste ich mal unseren Trainern in Frankfurt
erzählen. Ich glaube, die wissen das. Die kennen das
einfach noch nicht.
Ich sollte mich mal wieder melden
und sagen, Jungs, wisst ihr eigentlich?
Ihr könnt euren gesamten Job vergessen.
Einfach Shisha plus Laptop
gleich Money.
Ja, da könnte wirklich was dran sein.
Man muss ja das Bild eines erfolgreichen
Geschäftsmanns erzeugen, damit die Leute denken,
ah, guck mal, der ist ja wirklich erfolgreich.
Mit seiner Hilfe kann ich das auch schaffen.
Aber, dass ApoRed dafür Werbung
macht, ist wahrscheinlich die größte Red Flag,
die man dabei überhaupt noch haben kann.
Moment mal, ApoRed
macht Werbung dafür?
Ich hab jetzt in keinem Video,
keiner Instagram-Story oder sonst wo gelesen,
dass es sich dabei um Werbung handelt.
Stimmt. Also, entweder
mag ApoRed Lukas wirklich sehr gerne
und hat ihm einen kleinen Gefallen getan.
Oder, wenn er in irgendeiner Form
beteiligt ist, ist das Werbung
und müsste dann leider auch
gekennzeichnet werden.
Ja, wer sonst irgendwie...
Der macht das bestimmt nur aus reiner Nächstenliebe.
Verboten. Also, sowohl im Video
als auch in der Insta-Story müsste ja dann
so eine kleine Markierung da oben irgendwie sein.
Der markierende Hase war halt nicht am Start.
Alles klar, das werde ich direkt
nach dem Anwalt schicken.
Und ich weiß nicht so ganz, aber ich hab das Gefühl,
dass sich Lukas so fresh und nice findet.
Und so oft hier dazu aufgerufen wird,
doch endlich auf diesen verkackten Link zu klicken.
Aber, ob das jetzt so zutreffend ist,
das müssen vielleicht auch andere Menschen
einfach entscheiden. Ich verstehe aber immer noch nicht ganz,
wie es eigentlich zu dieser ganzen Sache kommen konnte.
Entweder ApoRed hat wirklich seinen guten Kumpel da
und die beiden wollen sich ein richtig großes Business
aufbauen, oder
ApoRed braucht einfach Geld.
Und mit Blick auf die ganzen Infos
das kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen.
Der agile Enjoyer
hat gesubbt. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Hab ich gar nicht gesehen. Wurde wirklich nicht angezeigt, oder?
Warum wurde das nicht angezeigt?
BlackHD, dich hab ich gesehen,
aber den agilen
Enjoyer?
Vielleicht hast du auch... Ja doch, tatsächlich.
Ich weiß nicht, warum das nicht angezeigt wurde. Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil du
suspicious user activity bist.
Twitch ist der Meinung, du hast irgendwas angestellt.
Danke für den Sub.
Pogu.
Software ist doch eher wahrscheinlich.
YouTuber und Influencer verdienen ja vor allen Dingen
ihre Kohle über Werbeverträge und Kooperationen.
Bei dem Stand, den ApoRed gerade hat,
sieht das aber damit bisschen
schwierig aus. Da gibt's halt nicht so viele Firmen,
die sich denken,
wir müssen jetzt unbedingt mal mit ApoRed werben.
Doch, gibt es. Ohne Scheiß.
Also,
ich kann euch das...
Du kriegst laufend Anfragen.
Sogar ich. Ich mach so wenig Youtube
in letzter Zeit.
Ich habe meine letzten videos die
Ich das zwei wochen her vier wochen der ein monat her ein monat her
Und sogar ich bekomme die schwachsinnigsten anfragen
Den es vollkommen egal ist was ich für einen channel bin und mobile games bis
Ein gutes penis verlängerung jetzt nicht mehr aber was haben wir denn sonst noch ich lese ich lese euch mal so ein paar tolle sachen vor
Was haben wir denn hier so
Was was haben wir denn hier so weit ich gehe mal kurz ja e-mail post eingang
guten tag max fps
Cyberghostvpn fragt ob ich was machen möchte ok nächster
Dann fragt
Irgendwas irgendeine neue chat app keine ahnung was das ist fragt an
Dann
Möchte irgendjemand eine 60 bis 90 sekunden integrationen kaufen für
Was ist das in den mobile game so anfragen kriegt aporette garantiert auch und das könnte der auch machen das ist halt
Es ist halt auch schrott irgendwo aber allemal besser als
Die leute mit irgendwelchen komischen telegram gruppen zu scannen
Jetzt da müssten wir echt mal wieder was machen daher ich hätte sogar bock drauf und wir könnten sogar da was
native kubernetes mäßiges zeigen
Sonst keine
Reinkommen dann muss man halt auf sowas zurückgreifen
Naja ich hoffe einfach mal dass möglichst wenig menschen da ihre kohle verlieren aber vielleicht habe ich auch einfach nicht das richtig
Ich habe mit hetzer schon was gemacht aber das ist ein bisschen eingeschlafen was aber auch daran liegt
dass ich dieses jahr eigentlich so oft ja fast nichts mehr sponsoring mäßig
mich darum gekümmert habe
Anfang des jahres hatten wir noch kurz was gemacht
Das letzte größere war glaube ich zum neuen standort von hetzer in den usa und
Vor vorletztes jahr oder so wo wir wer gemacht haben
da war ich
Auch ein bisschen mehr hinterher so mit mit neuen sachen die man irgendwie bin ich gerade total unmotiviert mich um irgendwelche sponsoring sachen zu kommen
zu kümmern
Guten vpn dienst muss ja erstmal überlegen warum du den haben willst und ob du den überbrauchst
Wahrscheinlich willst du geoblocking sachen umgehen und sonst was kann man mit vpn machen muss man nicht unbedingt mit vpn man kann mit vpn machen
Nein kann ich dir keine empfehlen weil ich persönlich macht das immer so wenn ich ip adressen
Aus anderen ländern oder wenn ich so wenn ich so aussehen soll als komme ich aus anderen ländern mit meinen anfragen
Dann mache ich das selbst da miete ich mir irgendeine vm in dem jeweiligen ziel land sei es bei hetzer sei es bei digital ocean
Also jetzt da geht ganz gut für die usa und digital ocean geht zum beispiel ganz gut
in indien
Oder tunnele ich mich da schnell drüber das ist eine sache von
Zwei drei minuten bis das bis ich ein browser habe mit einem
Proxy wo ich in indien rauskommen das das dauert zwei drei minuten es geht mega schnell
commandline tool
Vm hochfahren einloggen pssh mit sox proxy browser redirecten fertig
Was kostet so eine vm
paar cent weil
guck mal weil
Immer mal digital ocean pricing
Du siehst ein droplet das ist eine vm bei den kostet vier euro im monat aber
Es wird minuten genau abgerechnet glaube das sieht man jetzt hier gar nicht gescheit es wird minuten genau abgerechnet guck mal mal
hetzer cloud pricing
Preising guck hier siehst du es also
Nimmst du mal sowas share cpu arm oder kannst du auch eine x-axis ein prinzip egal du musst gucken wo location usa ist
Hier ist location usa
Ja nimmst du so eine kiste
Nimmst du eine kiste bezahlst acht nee du bezahlst 0,8 cent sehe ich das richtig die stunde
Und du brauchst die vm ja nur für die zeit wo du was machen willst
Und also ich kaufe mir zum beispiel immer youtube premium über über vpn also über vpn über über den proxy in indien weil es einfach
Richtig nice günstig ist da fahre ich eine vm hoch
Erbinde mich dort per ssh drauf machen sox proxy auf und öffnen browser da drüber geht also sprich das ist eine sache von wirklich
Zwei drei minuten dann habe ich einen browser mit in der indischen ip und kann dann alles machen was ich da will
Was braucht man youtube premium zum beispiel dass es keine werbung gibt oder oder dass man youtube musik gescheit benutzen kann
Das kann man auch machen ja automatisch verlängern das einzige ist man muss ein zahlungsprofil anlegen neues indisches zahlungsprofil in seinem google account
Dann dann geht das habe ich gehört würde ich natürlich nicht selbst machen
Ja, also es ist es ist günstig und es wird stundengenau abgerechnet das heißt im endeffekt
Google mal du wirst schon herausfinden du wirst du wirst also im endeffekt wahrscheinlich für das vpn für die kurze zeit wo du es brauchst
Keine ahnung zwei cent bezahlen oder so
Kann man so ein tunneling eigentlich auch extern machen also beispielsweise jemand geht auf meine webseite und ich biete ihm das an
das kannst du machen wenn wenn
Du dich auf den stress einlassen willst kannst du das machen
Jetzt weiß ich warum du manchmal timeout wurde so lass mal gucken was können wir uns als nächstes für video geben
Ich habe fast den eindruck chainlaw hat neuen account
Ein typischer tag als softwareentwickler
smartphone
Gegen kameras der das gute bei smartphones ist als immer dabei hast das nicht extra einpassen muss
ein typischer tag als softwareentwickler ok
Die videos von dem sind also in dieser richtung sind eigentlich wirklich gut die sind meistens nicht wir spielen den halben tag tischkicker
lass mal gucken
nachdem wir uns jetzt
45 minuten lang
Telegram scan gegeben haben brauche ich ein bisschen was für mehr high IQ
Stimmt was hat er denn?
Was hat er denn wieder neues zeigt mal her
nix
was juckt
Warum so wenige tabs ja ich weiß ganz schön cringe aber ich habe glücklicherweise hier noch ein paar und da
Level cap gibt es glaube ich auch nichts spannendes oder hat level cap wieder was was irgendwas was ist das
Irgendwas spannendes
Cheating in battle bit ja dass da wie verrückt gecheatet wird wundert mich nicht
Wahrscheinlich ich meine die haben battle eye glaube ich am start als anti cheat aber je nachdem wie gut das in dem spiel gemacht ist
ist fraglich ob das
Das alles so gut verhindert also da muss ich echt sagen da war overwatch wirklich gut
Overwatch hat ja einen riesen cheater problem im asiatischen raum witzigerweise aber ansonsten eigentlich gar nicht so großartig
Und und gerade im asiatischen raum gibt es ja länder da musst du dich für online accounts mit einer password id und sowas
registrieren und wenn du gebannt wirst bist du gebannt
So
Lass uns doch gerade mal reinschauen
Smartphone gegen kameras
Labortest mit iphone samsung also ich meine oh guck mal dungeon keeper ein richtig nicer gaming enjoyer hier am start
Dungeon keeper ist eines meiner absoluten lieblings games of all time
und das schöne ist
Das ist für dungeon keeper nur falls irgendjemand bock hat das originale dungeon keeper mal auf modernen pc zu spielen
Keeper fx github könnt ihr euch das installieren und dann unterstützt dungeon keeper auch höhere auflösung
Als das originale game und sieht automatisch auch noch besser aus
Dungeon keeper ist wirklich eins der besten games was ich je gespielt habe
Okay, auch 21 minuten ist mir jetzt eigentlich zu lang
Was haben wir denn sonst noch so das verdient ein grundschullehrer
ich will
jetzt euch mal was sagen
Ich glaube lehrer
Nicht nur grundschullehrer lehrer allgemein das ist glaube ich eines der schlimmsten berufe die ich mir für mich vorstellen kann
Ich weiß nicht was mit dem sebaro los ist
Dass er das freiwillig machen will aber gut soll jeder machen was er will
Ich könnte mir nichts
Schlimmeres also fast nichts schlimmeres vorstellen job mäßig als lehrer zu sein
Ja es geht mir auch so so viel geld könnten die mir gar nicht bezahlen dass ich das freiwillig machen würde guck mal mal was der verdient
Wahrscheinlich nicht genug für den stress
Gute laune
Ein guter tag ist für mich wenn die kinder alles verstehen ich brauche jetzt keine millionen das ist jetzt nicht mein ziel also dass ich da jetzt irgendwie
Wie das ist aber nicht das high performer mindset der müsst auch mal in die gruppe
Ich werde wenn ich mir das anschaue dann ist gewaltig etwas schief gegangen ich sag guten morgen liebe kinder
Hallo mein name ist lukas jucht das fand ich schon in selbst in der schule immer cringe dieses wir stehen auf und begrüßen den lehrer
Ich bin 26 jahre alt und von beruf grundschullehrer hier an der grundschule in treuchtlingen ich bin jetzt
Klassenlehrer einer vierten klasse zum ersten mal
Kannst du bitte den stream unterbrechen und pausieren mein hund möchte runter
Da musste die 258 andere leute fragen ob ich jetzt den stream unterbrechen kann
Da musste die 258 andere leute fragen ob ich jetzt den stream erst mal pausieren soll bis dann paul wieder am start ist
Dienstag finde ich immer sehr schön weil sechs stunden meiner klasse habe
Das ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht wenn du am stück die gleichen also sowohl für die schüler als auch für die lehrer
Der chat ist für pause so so na dann
Dann lass mal schnell einen hund raus wir wollen ja mal nicht so sein also wir hatten in der berufsschule
Wir hatten in der berufsschule so ein tool was der ich glaube ich glaube der datenbanklehrer war das
Der hat das selbst programmiert in dort nett witzigerweise
Haben wir so ein selbst programmiertes programm von unserem datenbanklehrer auf jedem rechner drauf gehabt mit dem er zentral
Die bildschirme sperren konnte der leute das ding war nur war nur so dass es dermaßen schlecht programmiert gewesen dass du es abschießen
Konntest mit dem telnet befehl
Hatten wir auch ja aber das bei mir war selbst programmiert vom datenbank
lehrer zumindest
du konntest einfach nen
netzwert machen auf
Deine lokale kiste gucken auf welchen port das lauscht dann bist du per telnet auf den port gegangen hast dich connectet und hast random
Irgendwas eingegeben und dann ist das tool gecrasht weil es den in den input nicht richtig validiert hat
Und dann hattest du den einzigen rechner dann nicht gesperrt werden konnte vom lehrer
Ne das ist irgendwas was der lehrer selbst gebaut hat bei uns
Mit rast wäre das nicht passiert ja mit rast hätte es der lehrer wahrscheinlich gar nicht auf die reihe gekommen dass es überhaupt was
lauffähiges rauskommt
Das war jetzt nicht der
allergrößte
Softwareentwicklung checker auch auch wenn es auch wenn er datenbanken unterrichtet hat
Ja es gibt schon enorm viel schrott gibt es auch noch eine andere story bei uns hier im ort
Zu zeiten als man noch in die bibliothek gegangen ist
hatten die also das war dann so
1998 oder so fragt mich nicht schon ewig her da hatten die dort auch ein computer da konnte man sich internetzeit mieten
musste man eben noch so geld in so einen schlitz reinschmeißen
Und
Dann konnte man konnte man im internet surfen ansonsten wurde der gesperrt
Und was man machen konnte ist also es war es war so ziemlich alles gesperrt auf dem rechner außer
wird
Einen browser und so also du konntest auch nicht auf dem desktop und groß was machen aber jetzt haltet euch mal fest wisst ihr was man
Machen konnte das war auch ein eingekauftes tut ich vermute das war damals noch windows 98 oder so was was man machen konnte was ich
Damals rausbekommen habe ist du konntest in word kannst du ja verknüpfungen einfügen ja also normale leute fügen da bilder ein und so was aber
Du konntest damals in word auch verknüpfungen einfügen zur windows hilfe zum beispiel
Und über die windows hilfe konntest du cmd starten wahrscheinlich jetzt direkt direkt cmd starten ging nicht
Du konntest quasi cmd starten über word was nicht weil wird nicht gelockt war
So und dann konntest du cmd starten und dann konntest du das ausschalten und theoretisch hättest du weiter den computer nutzen können auch wenn deine
Deine quasi eingeworfene coinzeit abgelaufen ist
Weil es wurde damit nichts gemacht außer der bildschirm gesperrt
Es war es war weird also ich habe das auch versucht einer in der bücherei zu erklären
Dass die dass das ziemlich anfällig ist die system das hat er sich versucht aufzuschreiben
Hat es aber wahrscheinlich absolut nicht gecheckt
Ist der hund raus oder oder meint er mit hund raus er geht jetzt gassi weil so lange warte ich nicht
Ich hätte dich einfach rausgeschmissen
Kennt ihr das noch rausschmeißen und türklinke runterhalten dass der lehrer weiß man ist noch da wer war auch schon mal
Türklinken halte haltungs enjoyer kann mich doch ich kann mich noch an eine
Sache erinnern richtig richtig dumm mit zwei zwei sachen zwei sachen
Richtig hängen geblieben und zwar
Bei uns bei uns also es hatte ja jeder irgendwelche dummen worte die er damit seinen kollegen in der schule
Mit seinen freunden aus der schule immer erzählt hat so und wir hatten irgendwann mal so einen tick
Das ist eigentlich richtig cringe und dämlich ja aber wir hatten mal irgendwann so einen tick in der schule
Das ist eigentlich richtig cringe und dämlich ja aber wir hatten mal irgendwann so einen tick in der schule dass wir das wort chicken
vor alles
Gehängt haben
Also chicken also hähnchen ja und wir hatten dann irgendwann in geschichte hatten wir nelson mandela
Als thema und wir haben das für eine tolle idee gehalten dass das nicht nelson mandela ist sondern chicken mandela
Und irgendwann hat dann halt haben dann halt die leute angefangen
Wenn der lehrer was wissen wollte den typ nicht nelson mandela zu nennen sondern chicken mandela
Irgendwann wenn ihr jetzt noch weiter macht mit diesem blödsinn dann schmeiße ich euch raus und natürlich
So wie wir damals in der schule waren bei nächstes bei der nächsten gelegenheit ja chicken mandela
Kann ich mich daran erinnern so ein schwachsinn
Chicken mandela
Krasse hacker männer
Ja es gibt immer so blöde sprüche halt ja
Und wir haben einmal richtig ärger bekommen da kann ich mich auch
Bis da paul wieder da ist also zwei minuten gebe ich ihm noch zeit ja noch zwei noch zwei sachen aus der aus der schule eingestreut
Wir haben mal richtig ärger bekommen
Von das war nicht unser unser lehrer das war wahrscheinlich so der der hat mich nicht
Abteilungsleiter da würde ich sagen wie nennt man das in der schule stufenleiter oder so da mussten wir nämlich hin weil wir
Ein mitschüler zu sehr geärgert haben und ich will das nicht gut reden aber ich bin immer noch der meinung wir haben ihn gar nicht
Wirklich so geärgert aber und mir war auch gar nicht klar dass ihn das so krass geärgert hat
Aber der hat sich wohl wirklich übelst abgefuckt gefühlt durch uns und zwar wir hatten jemand
In der klasse
Da waren wir der meinung dass der halt so voll
Nach nach militär aussieht ja so super kurze haare und er ist auch immer so so
So stramm gelaufen und so und irgendwann haben wir halt gesagt okay wenn der jetzt wenn der jetzt an uns vorbeiläuft das salutieren wir
so vor dem
Und das haben wir dann paar wochen gemacht immer vor dem mitschüler so blöd salutiert ja und
Das scheint ihn so krass aufgeregt zu haben dass er einen nervenzusammenbruch
bekommen hat und
Ist dann ist dann zum lehrer und hat sich beschwert und haben wir richtig ärger gekriegt
Oh
Mann aber ich habe es in der schule auch oft genug abgekriegt also ist nicht so als als
Hätte ich nur leute geärgert also ich habe ich habe es auch übelst übelst abgekriegt zum beispiel zum beispiel eine sache die mich auch
übelst übelst abgefuckt hat
Ist eigentlich in der heute das wäre in der heutigen zeit gar kein thema mehr
Da daran sieht man dass ich dass ich das alles schon ein bisschen ein bisschen geändert hat und zwar
Ich hatte aus der parallelklasse damals ein mit dem habe ich übelst gut verstanden ja der gehörte zwar nicht so zu unserem wie nennt man
Das so zu unserem circle irgendwie dabei aber mit dem habe ich gut verstanden mit dem habe ich in der pause öfters
Da mal zusammengestanden geschwätzt und so und irgendjemand hat dann erzählt ja der max und ich weiß gar nicht wie der typ heiß
Jan oder so glaube ich hieß der ja die sind zusammen die sind schwul hat dann irgendjemand rum erzählt in der schule ja
Und damals war halt wenn einer gesagt hat in schwul das war doch die krasseste beleidigung ever
Oder hat man sich übelst abgefuckt gefühlt dadurch
Genau heute heute hätte ich gesagt ja und weiter willst du auch mal
Also das hat mich damals dann übelst genervt heute wäre das wahrscheinlich gar kein großartiges thema
Vpn zu einer schule gesperrt
Okay, paul jetzt aber lange noch gewartet das reicht jetzt also genug zeit zum hund raus zum hund raus lassen
Wir haben es glaube ich wie lange haben wir jetzt gewartet
Ja
neun minuten
Das reicht jetzt um den hund rauszulassen wir gucken uns jetzt mit dem lehrer weiter an
Ich will das so genau will ich das nicht wissen
Jetzt weiß ich wie gesagt ich weiß schon warum du ab zu timeout wurdest mortges
jemand da mod check top
Okay gucken wir uns mal weiter an was man als lehrer so verdient ich habe jetzt zehn minuten gewartet also
Sport das macht mir persönlich auch viel spaß weil es einfach mal so eine abwechslung ist
Was was macht das sport?
Davon zwei stunden sport das macht mir persönlich auch viel spaß weil es einfach mal
so eine abwechslung ist
Gottes abbild ich gebe dir mal einen tipp installiert ihr ffz oder irgendeines der anderen twitch addons
Dann kannst du das wieder rückgängig machen guck hier ich könnte hier drauf klicken
Und dann könnte ich die nachricht noch sehen obwohl sie deletet wurde ich bin jetzt derzeit beamter auf probe
Das wird jetzt voraussichtlich noch
Anderthalb jahre etwa dauern und dann beginnt für mich das beamtenverhältnis auf lebens oder ab dann wird nicht mehr gearbeitet
Zeit fühlt sich gut an auf jeden fall hat man natürlich auch die pension als großer vorteil weil ja doch dem die ja sehr hoch ausfällt
Guten morgen
Also in hsu in heimat und sachunterricht auf jeden fall europa
Dann habe ich noch zwei stunden sport da machen wir leichtathletik weit sprung
Und dann noch deutsch und mathe man darf ja bis auf ausnahmen alles unterrichten es sei denn halt zum beispiel für religionen da braucht man
halt eine lehrer
fähigung oder eine lehrerlaubnis guten morgen
Religion
Brauche eine lehrer ok ok ich verstehe es irgendwie aber warum darfst du als jemand oder ist es denn sinnvoll
Sagen wir als jemand der ich sich gut mit geschichte auskennt ist es da wirklich sinnvoll physik zu unterrichten
Ein guter tag ist heute für mich wenn die kinder alles verstehen was ich aus dem gibt es überhaupt noch religion ich dachte die machen nur
noch ethik
Also ich hatte die ehre fast ehre
Ja ich hatte die ehre noch religion machen zu dürfen der grundschule ich fand das immer so kacke
Und ich war froh dass es dann irgendwann nur noch ethik gab also wir hatten auch noch ethik in der berufsschule
Die lehrerin war aber krank und wir hatten glaube ich nur zweimal ethik in der gesamten ausbildung haben alle zwei gekriegt
Wo sich dann sogar noch leute beschwert haben so nach dem motto warum das liegt doch nicht an uns warum kriegen wir nicht alle eins
Ich mir hier überlegt habe jetzt heute merke ich natürlich dann wie es wie die kinder darauf anspringen ob sie wirklich fleißig
Ich sage guten morgen liebe kinder
Das ist so schlimm
Aber
Sie sind doch so lieb alle guckt euch an
Die klasse macht die klasse ist auch gar nicht so groß naja doch wie viele leute haben wir hier 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 leute das ist ja noch voll überschaubar
Typisch mache das ist sowas was gang und gäbe ist eigentlich im grundschulbereich um so rituale schon
anzubahnen
dass die kinder strukturen haben
Was gibt das jetzt wenn es fertig ist
Ist es ein bisschen
Sonnig und ein bisschen kalt
Ein bisschen kalt na vielleicht vielleicht mild angenehm noch aber später wird es glaube ich auf jeden fall sehr sehr heiß dann
sage ich auf die plätze fertig los
Was war das jetzt der tägliche wetterbericht oder was
Hä das verstehe dass das habe ich nicht kapiert jetzt
Daily scrum oder was waren die da
Chat habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht die sind die lernen schon wie man agil ist
Sehr gut wie du siehst geht es um europa
Okay das hätte ich auch noch hinbekommen ja so nach dem motto rom berlin paris
Bei allen anderen sachen wäre es schon schwierig geworden ja
deswegen gibt es schöne station die ich für euch vorbereitet habe dann auf geht's
Die zwei jahre vorbereitungsdienst waren ja wie wenn man ins kalte wasser springen muss dann hatte ich auf einmal
Die volle verantwortung hat man schon gesehen was er verdient ich habe gar nicht richtig hingeguckt
ach hier
Median gerallt grundschule 4.600 euro brutto
Als beamter bezahlst du allerdings wahrscheinlich nicht so viel steuern muss sich aber selbst kranken versichern kriegst dann wahrscheinlich ein bisschen besseren tarif oder so
also was meint ihr was davon übrig bleiben wird werden wir am ende wahrscheinlich sehen aber
Bleiben da am ende übrig 3000 euro
ohne dass noch irgendjemand dabei ist und dann lernt man wirklich dazu und und auch das scheitern gehört dazu so dass man
etwas nicht mehr wieder macht
Ich hoffe das sagt er auch wenn einer voll verkackt hat und eine fünf oder sechs schreibt macht auch ach hier tim
nicht so wild scheitern gehört dazu so das klingt jetzt fatal also das waren halt einfach
arbeitsblätter die zu schwierig waren zum beispiel und die kinder haben es überhaupt nicht verstanden und dann gab es halt am ende ein riesen geschrei
Wenn du mal schaust suchst du ein paar orientierungspunkte hier ist es schwarz hin soll einfach in die gruppe easy reich muss er nichts
lernen mehr das ist hier
Das heißt du musst noch ein bisschen weitergehen
Das habe ich vorhin schon der mara erklärt vielleicht kannst du mal
Kannst du die mara um hilfe fragen aber wenn du mal ein bisschen guckst vielleicht dass du es nur mal siehst efa die karte
Oh da bist ja wieder ja du hast drei minuten video verpasst
Ich habe nicht gedacht dass ein gassi gehen so lange dauert hier die mara auch gehört hat das eigentlich ganz gut denn das siehst
Du wirklich nur europa
Also wirklich lob an die ganze klasse wirklich gut gearbeitet denkt daran nach der pause sport das heißt wenn du reinkommst beeil dich dass wir
uns gleich
losmachen können
Die sind so brav alle das ist doch nicht realistisch oder
Ich stelle mir ich stelle mir ganz
Noch ich stelle mir das schrecklich vor so eine schulklasse
Meine kamera da ist ja ja wahrscheinlich aber gut ich meine wer weiß
Wie weiß wie das an irgendeiner brennpunktschule ablaufen würde
Da muss erst mal waffenkontrolle am eingang gemacht werden ich möchte möchte dass du bitte eine kappe mit der lehre beendet die stunde genau
Das hat uns unser klassenlehrer auch immer erzählt dass sein lieblings spruch war wenn es geklingelt hat und alle eingepackt haben hat er immer gesagt
Das klingelzeichen ist ein vager hinweis für den lehrer er möge doch den unter den unterricht innerhalb der nächsten 15 minuten beenden
Ich habe keine ahnung ob das wirklich stimmt aber das war sein lieblings spruch wenn es geklingelt hat die leute alle eingepackt haben
längst also wir werden nicht lange rausgehen weil schon sehr warm ist aber wir werden einen teil draußen machen und ein teil in der halle
Meistens gehe ich ins lehrerzimmer runter und ja
Haben wir ein bisschen austausch dann das eigentlich mal ganz schön man man nutze ich auch die zeit um etwas weg zu korrigieren
Oh ja da erinnere ich mich auch noch dran dass die ganze nutze ich auch die zeit
Dass die ganzen hefte je nach fach immer nur unterschiedliche unterschiedliche farben ich habe das auch gehasst
Meine einbindung so war noch immer kaputt ihr kennt mich leute ich bin übelst unordentlich ich war in der schule schon mega unordentlich
Ich war in der schule schon mega unordentlich die matte war blau matte war bei uns auch blau das weiß ich noch
Ich überlege gerade ob ich zusammenkriege englisch war glaube ich rot
Englisch war glaube ich rot matte war blau also so erdkundige geschichte zoll war glaube ich grün
Mehr weiß ich nicht
Sie könnte braun gewesen sein also ich sehe jetzt von schule zu schule unterschiedliche
Warum ist das nicht einheitlich gerät wozu auch so egal
Um etwas weg zu korrigieren
Während des vorbereitungsdienstes kriegt man auch gehalt das ist natürlich
Deutlich weniger als im ersten vorbereitungs also im ersten jahr des vorbereitungsdienstes sind
1300 etwa netto und im zweiten jahr
1500 euro netto
Davon hätte ich erst mal appetit bekommen drei gurken und ein keks das esse ich und danach denke ich mir okay wann kommt denn jetzt das richtige essen
Ella heißt auf griechisch glaube ich zack zack
Das weiß ich auch nur weil ich mmo immer mit einem griechisch spiele
Und mir das im discord anhören muss und er sagt laufen ella
Glaubt das heißt auf griechisch schnell schnell werde das jetzt die kinder halt hier
Sich weniger an die regeln halten also zum klassenzimmer weil es jetzt einfach hier natürlich mehr bewegung ist alles offener
Und da muss man natürlich auch hier wieder einfach klar dann kommunizieren und eben dann auch intervenieren wenn dann halt verstoße kommen sportklamotten
Schlange haare zopf
Gesundheit schmuck und uhren
Nicole aha haben wir noch was ansonsten gute laune warum
Ach ja weil wir sonst hängenbleiben könnte
Wir haben am freitag auch das sportfest also denkt daran das heißt es ist unsere letzte probe sozusagen
spielen
Ich habe ich habe ich irgendwo auch noch ein paar urkunden bundesjugendspiele das war das mal überlegen weitwurf
Weitsprung und 100 meter rennen
Wenn ich das auch niemand konnte sich aussuchen ob 100 meter rennen oder ein kilometer jongen so
war das glaube ich
Ja das war die zeit wo ich ziemlich trainiert war da konnte ich da konnte ich das alles ganz gut ich möchte
Paar urkunden ja ich habe fast jedes jahr ich habe da ich habe da ordentlich
urkunden abgesahnt bei den bundesjugendspielen
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so als bekommt bei den bundesjugendspielen irgendwie nur die ersten drei urkunden du bekommst glaube ich
Es gibt eine goldurkunde es gibt eine silberurkunde
und ich glaube alle die quasi in einem gewissen
Prozentsatz liegen kriegen da die urkunde also da werden massenhaft urkunde da muss man sich nichts großartig darauf einbilden
Also in der zeit war ich wirklich war ich wirklich ziemlich ziemlich sportlich ja da konnte ich fünf kilometer schwimmen
Ohne dass mich das irgendwie geschockt hat und ich meine wirklich fünf kilometer
nicht irgendwie fünf runden oder so
teilnehmerurkunde gab es ziemlich sicher nicht es gab nur silber und gold
Also ich konnte kilometer schwimmen und und im prinzip auch kann mich noch daran erinnern wenn ich im kreis gerannt bin
Auf der bahn da musste dann irgendwann sogar jemand sagen so es reicht jetzt mal also
Ich war zu dem zeitpunkt hier gerade wo die in dem alter so war ich übelst trainiert
Danach danach ging es an danach habe ich irgendwann ein computer bekommen und habe nur noch vom rechner gehockt
Und dann ging es bergab mit der fitness
Mit dir am anfang mich hier in der halle warm machen weil es draußen schon gut warm ist
schnick schnack schnuck und dann ihn fangen dann gasal fangen und dann kam der mmo kreis und kreien
Ich habe eigentlich relativ früh so achte klasse neunte klasse langsam mit dem gedanken gespielt das
Lehramt an sich könnte etwas für mich sein
Damals haben mich vor allem halt ich kann es nicht verstehen wie man freiwillig lehrer werden kann also es ist mir unbegreiflich
Also mich regen ja normale menschen schon auf die pure existenz und anwesenheit in meiner nähe von normalen menschen nervt mich ja schon
Kinder ist noch mal so eine extra schippe obendrauf die nerven mich noch mehr das heißt hauptberuflich mit kinder
Zusammenarbeiten ist glaube ich das schrecklichste was ich mir vorstellen könnte wobei ich sagen muss eventuell nicht umso älter sie werden umso mehr nervig werden
Sie ja wahrscheinlich noch also wenn die event wenn die erst mal 12 13 14 sind ich glaube dann fangen die dich noch mehr ab
Also hätte ich auch keinen bock drauf
Das wäre jetzt das schlimmste beruf den ich mir vorstellen könnte
Ja zwei meiner lehrkräfte sehr geprägt ja da habe ich gedacht ne das imponiert mir
Wie die so mit mir umgehen wir treffen uns hier draußen wieder dann schatten weil das habe ich aber keinem lehrer gedacht
Springen ich habe hier
Zonen aufgebaut du siehst sechs zonen das ist für dich so eine kleine orientierung
Dass du dir ein bisschen ein ziel vornehmen kann
Super muss der fahrt du hättest du gar noch ein gutes stück weitergehen können die waren beide klasse immer dann gut
die haupttätigkeiten des grundschullehrers sind natürlich das unterrichten der kinder aber auch das erziehen also das
Hält sich eigentlich immer so die wage gerade im grundschulbereich ich will dir mal so ein bisschen zeigen was
Was manche kinder hier fabriziert haben bei den hausaufgaben wenn ich mir das anschaue so soll das bild aussehen
Und so schaut es dann aus dann ist gewaltig etwas schiefgegangen tatsächlich war das moment was machen die da
Was was soll das geben wie man den zirkel benutzt oder was
Und so schaut es dann aus dann ist gewaltig etwas schiefgegangen
Guck mal guck mal da steht der name drunter von wem das ist oder
Dann können sich jetzt ja alle über lustig machen dass er kein kreis malen kann dann aus dann ist gewaltig etwas schiefgegangen
Tatsächlich war das zirkel jetzt ein ganz neues thema das haben wir das letzte woche angefangen darum war das auch zum teil noch chaotisch
Das üben ist oder ist es oder ist es der lehrer
Der da unten unterschrieben ja gut in dem alter unterschreibt man noch nicht
Und das o aber achtung du misst jetzt den durchmesser
Und wir wollen jetzt zum zeichnen ist wahrscheinlich leichter wenn du den radius misst
Warte kurz paul
Nee, guck du misst dann den mittelpunkt wo wo ist der mittelpunkt von paul ist vom gassi gehen wieder da diesen kleinen kreis
Genau und da legst du das lineares geodreieck an
Wer war noch ja nicole
Keine hausaufgaben wir sehen uns dann morgen ich wünsche euch einen schönen nachmittag mit viel abkühlung hoffentlich viel eis
Die will noch was wissen wird erst mal ignoriert und so weiter ich sag auf wiedersehen liebe kinder
Die ausbüttel
Erstmal komplett ignoriert kämpft sich wie du hast so eine frage
Man muss jetzt erst mal wirklich runterkommen weil es dann doch irgendwie alles schon auch stress natürlich innerlich ist man
Ist man wirklich die ganze zeit im tunnel also man muss halt wirklich funktionieren ich bin ja im prinzip
Für 25 kinder jetzt ich also doch 25 haben wir uns doch leicht verzählt
der ansprechpartner ich verdiene
4097 euro brutto netto bleiben wir dann
3273 euro haben wir gut geschätzt jett ich meine davon kann man denke ich ganz gut leben
Übrig von diesem betrag geht dann noch ein kleiner teilbetrag in die
Vermögenswirksamen leistungen als beamter zahle ich noch eine private krankenversicherung ein das sind
272 euro im monat und somit bleiben wir am ende dann zwar das aber relativ gute ist aber auch noch jung
1988 oder was ich jetzt als positiv empfinde ist die angleichung des gehaltes von grundschullehrkräften
Auf 13 aktuell ist es noch so dass grundschullehrkräfte mit 12 einsteigen also dass diese einstiegs
besoldungsstufe
Eine gymnasiale kraft einer realschullehrkraft beispielsweise die starten schon mit 13
Wenn ich nach hause komme dann sieht man tag
Eigentlich immer ein bisschen unterschiedlich außer das hängt vor allem davon erst mal arbeiten korrigieren ab ob ich jetzt noch was zu korrigieren mit
nach hause nehme
Ich bin jetzt seit anderthalb jahren in einer beziehung meine freundin die habe ich in würzburg kennengelernt an meiner alten schule
Was für mich jetzt eben ein ziel wäre ein eigenheim später also lege zwar was weg aber nicht mit dem konkret
bestermann
Etf bewusst sein irgendwann brauche ich dieses haus aber das fließt natürlich schon als hintergedanke mit rein
Dann machen wir uns mal los zum training
Hallo zusammen bei meiner freizeit ist es mir wichtig dass sie einen guten ausgleich darstellt zum beruf also ich mag dann gerne sport
Das verstehe ich das ist das ist übrigens auch der grund warum ich mich mittags eine hat zwei stunden mal ordentlich bewegen gehe
Weil ich sitze den ganzen tag vom rechner
Und mittlerweile fehlt mir auch was wenn ich mich nicht zwei eine hat zwei stunden am tag ist es in letzter zeit sogar eher richtung zwei
stunden mal ordentlich bewegt hab
Wenn ich da meine runden gedreht habe ansonsten
fehlt mir irgendwas ich da gut ausbauen kann weil ich hier richtig runter komme und auch wirklich den kopf dann abschalten kann
Der beruf als grundschullehrer lohnt sich definitiv
Für mich aus finanzieller sicht jetzt vor allem mit dem steigenden gehalt umso mehr aber auch aus
der sicht dass man wirklich
spaß
Im beruf haben kann
Und wie viel bleibt noch übrig
718 euro
Das ist tossmusik das ist bestimmt tosmusik das war der tag mit mir als grundschullehrer ich hoffe es hat euch sehr gefallen
Falls ihr noch weitere videos anschauen wollt ihr hier klicken für das video
Auch wenn ich null bock auf diesen beruf hätte hier klicken viel spaß beim anschauen
Ist er verbeamtet
Noch nicht ganz wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe der ist jetzt irgendwie so eine probe probebeamten status ist das ein review
Oder ist das einfach nur ein ja das ist das ist kein
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich noch kein review oder sind wir noch die early access an
Ja, da freue ich mich aber auch schon drauf auf baldur scale 3 habe ich richtig bock
Ist doch gut mal gucken ob es in zehn jahren lehrer immer noch so gechillt ist also viele lehrer die ich hatte haben also umso
Älter sie waren umso mehr hatten sie irgendwelche tics entwickelt
Das kommt wahrscheinlich mit dem beruf nach einer zeit
Gibt es heute wieder laxnudeln nein heute gibt es keine nudeln mit lax heute gibt es aber auch nudeln aber nicht mit lax
Aber noch kurz zeit
Lasst uns noch mal angucken ein typischer tag als softwareentwickler
Mal gucken ob er wieder aus spanien arbeiten darf
Das letzte video was wir von ihm geguckt haben war ich sitze ich sitze in spa ich sitze in spanien
an meinem laptop
Aber er hat tatsächlich den ganzen tag gearbeitet
Gucken ob er immer noch in spanien ist
okay
Okay, ich bin ja auch kein softwareentwickler da mache ich deswegen springe ich auch täglich nirgendswo runter verstehe ich
Ich bin ja nur wie sie quasi
gelernter da kann man nirgendswo runterspringen im sommer gibt es keine pause und es wird fleißig gekodet
Heute stehen zwei wichtige dinge an eine sache die wir gerade fertig programmiert haben und die neue
Aufgabe an der ich in der nächsten zeit arbeiten werde vor die arbeit aber los geht starte ich den tag mit einem lauf
Das dazu kann ich mich nicht vorstellen
Dafür mittags dann eineinhalb zwei stunden aber das klingt morgens kriegst du nicht auf die reihe mich zu bewegen
Außerdem wird es mir dann auch zu spät weil ich will ja 15 30 16 uhr spätestens schluss machen
Ich laufe ich laufe meine runde immer so nachmittags so
nach der arbeit zusammen so 16 16 uhr
So dass ich ja kurz nach 18 uhr oder so wieder daheim bin
Perfekte temperatur so ab 12 kann sie ja komplett vergessen da kann es eigentlich erst wieder okay das immer noch in spanien
Was machst du an extrem heißen tagen genau das gleiche eineinhalb zwei stunden
immer
also ich bin ja auch nicht so ein
Ich bin ja auch nicht so ein
Immer sogar heute normalerweise jeden tag jeden tag
Sonntag ist der einzige tag wo ich manchmal ausfallen lasse aber heute mache ich das auch wenn es nicht regnet
Also wenn es übelst regnet wie es teilweise angekündigt war aber ich habe vorhin wetterbericht geguckt sieht aus als ist es jetzt schon weg
Dann dann vielleicht eine kürzere runde aber ansonsten auch bei regen bei ultra heiß und sonst was eineinhalb zwei stunden ordentlich bewegung am tag
Ich kriege das auch sonst gar nicht mehr auf die reihe ich meine ich sitze vormittag die ganze zeit am rechner
Ich sitze nachmittags die ganze zeit am rechner ich sitze ich streame sitze am rechner ich passe es jetzt am rechner ich sitze im prinzip
Den großteil des tags am rechner da muss man einfach mal zwei stunden vom rechner rennen und sich ordentlich bewegen
Und das hat ja auch was gebracht also seit ich das regelmäßig mache und auch
Gewisser länge und mit einer gewissen ausdauer auch ordentlich abgenommen jetzt wieder ein bisschen weniger die letzten paar monate über
also ich habe
In den letzten eineinhalb jahren ungefähr 18 kilo 18 und ein halb kilo abgenommen
Seit und das das schiebe ich zum größten teil auf mehr bewegung ich habe das ja schon gesagt also
Essen hat sich nicht großartig was geändert das einzige was ich beim essen gerne ist vielleicht dass es ein
Ticken weniger fettig ist was ich jetzt esse aber es ist im prinzip immer noch das gleiche wie vorher vielleicht ein bisschen weniger fettig
Aber nicht nennenswert ist nicht so dass es komplett anderes essen wäre
Und vielleicht ein ticken mehr gemüse anstatt
Ungesunden kram aber im großen und ganzen ist es nicht das essen mit dem ich abgenommen habe sondern echt einfach mehr bewegen
Und dementsprechend gut was ich halt auch nicht mehr mache ist ich freue ich fresse abends keine chips mehr und sowas gibt keine chips mehr
Ansonsten das einzige was da wirklich große umstellung war ist die eineinhalb zwei stunden
Bewegung ich habe das vorher auch schon gemacht aber viel zu unregelmäßig und es ist halt echt ein unterschied ob du jeden tag
Deine runde drehst
Ich arbeite hier mit meinem komplett mobilen setup im prinzip besteht das aus meinem laptop und meinem ipad
Auch im büro habe ich leider nicht hätte ich persönlich keinen bock drauf
Ist mir zu klein und die tastatur auch und so
Ich meine ich bin ja sogar so ich bin ja sogar so drauf dass ich auf der arbeit obwohl ich dort
das alles gestellt bekomme
Also ich bekomme einen laptop und ich bekomme eine tastatur und eine maus und was man halt so braucht
Das einzige was ich auf der arbeit
Ne muss ich umgedreht sagen also ich benutze halt die maus und tastatur nicht ich habe sogar meine eigene maus und tastatur mitgebracht
Ich komme damit nicht klar wir haben also ich könnte auf der arbeit entweder das laptop laptop tastatur benutzen
Oder eben die tastatur die ich dabei bekommen habe
Aber das sind so low profile tastaturen mag ich nicht meine eigene ducky one skyline tastatur und eine g502 logitech maus
Sonst komme ich nicht klar das erste was ich morgens aus dem schrank hole und anschließe
Wenn ich mal nach frankfurt muss ja
Ich bin ja im vergleich zu früher ziemlich selten im büro
Ja das ist das ist tuni ja das ist so das das ding ist jeder weiß eigentlich
Dass es hilft wenn man sich ein bisschen bewegt ja gerade leute die ganzen tag vorm rechner sitzen
Ja leute die jetzt ganz auf der baustelle arbeiten haben genug bewegung aber leute wie wir die im büro sitzen vom rechnen ganz
Dach es weiß eigentlich jeder dass ein bisschen bewegung hilft für alles
Kreislauf kopfschmerzen muskelsachen alles hilft das aber
Der unterschied ist oder die die erkenntnis die man da erst mal haben muss ist okay ich weiß dass es so ist
Aber ich versuche das auch ein bisschen zu machen so dieser schritt von man weiß dass es so ist dass es was bringt
Das wusste ich das wusste ich auch schon immer
Aber hätte früher jemand gesagt auf max wir gehen jetzt mal eine halbe stunde raus und bewegen uns ein bisschen
Ich sage lass mich in ruhe ich will ein bisschen runde mmo kreiselkonten machen weiter vom rechner sitzen
Aber seitdem ich das angefangen haben das jetzt auch wirklich durchgehalten habe
muss ich sagen
Mir fehlt auch was am tag wenn ich das nicht mache
Ja es ist wirklich so ja ist so
Es muss es muss gar nicht so krass sein ja also ihr müsst jetzt nicht irgendwie jeden tag zwei stunden
Da irgendwie euren euren euren marathon könnte nicht rennen weil ich glaube der weltrekord liegt ja bei knapp zwei stunden
Ihr müsst jetzt nicht eure da irgendwie
20 kilometer
Jeden tag da das ist überhaupt nicht notwendig
Wichtig ist aber sich zu bewegen ich jogge ich jogge ja auch keine zwei stunden im kreis aber zwei stunden sich zu bewegen
Ist wirklich nice und selbst wenn es nur eine halbe stunde ist es ist alles besser als gar nichts so die ersten paar minuten
bringen schon wieder mehr als die nächsten minuten ich kann es wirklich jedem nur empfehlen
macht nordic walking mit stöcken oder so
das ist
bringt alles enorm viel
Versus nur vom rechner sitzen gerade wenn ihr viel kopfschmerzen habt und so
Das ist wirklich enormer unterschied ja du bist halt auch ein agiler enjoyer
Für nordic walking bis zu 20 jahre herum warum ich mache das auch
Auch gut ich bin auch 9 38
Da darf man das machen oder ist das es ist nordic walking mit 39 ist es schon okay
Oder ist das ja es ist glaube ich dass das da ist glaube ich in ordnung
ab 40
Aber ich laufe halt gerne auch ein bisschen außerhalb wo es hügel ich berge berge darf ich ja nicht sagen da regen sich die schweizer wieder auf
Wo es ein bisschen hügel gibt bei uns so im spessart und so bis in richtung spessart gefahren
Ich habe ja schon mal eine lieblingsrunde oder eine meiner lieblingsrunden mal im stream gezeigt
Ich finde das einfach gut wenn es nicht so nicht so schnurgerade immer immer eben ist sondern ein bisschen ein bisschen
Kurvig bisschen berghoch bisschen bergrunter
Natürlich sind zehn kilometer flach was ganz was anderes wie zehn kilometer mit berghoch und runter
Aber ich bevorzuge es trotzdem mit berghoch und runter erstens ist ein bisschen anstrengender und vor allem ist es halt viel weniger
langweilig und abwechslungsreicher
Kann es sein dass du aus der stadt raus willst ja auch natürlich ich fahre auch absichtlich ein bisschen weiter weg
20 20 15 bis 30 minuten je nachdem wo ich wo ich bock drauf habe mit dem auto
Und macht das macht es dann dort ja und da ist halt ein bisschen hügel ich ja
Ganz ehrlich es gibt nichts blöderes wie so eine schnurgerade ebene strecke das ist einfach langweilig als fakt da zählst du die minuten
bis du durch bist
Heigen brücken weiß ich nicht wo das ist heigen
Heigen brücken ist das
In bayern und wo in bayern
Das kenne ich nicht ist das ach hier
Mömmbris ne so weit so weit fahre ich nicht ich meine ich wohne ja hier so na und
Also das weiteste wo ich hinfahre ist eigentlich hier so richtung richtung alzenau mömmbris in die wenn ich in die richtung fahre das ist zu weit
Sieht aber auch sehr nett aus die umgebung da
Läuft bei dir dann eigentlich musik oder podcast
Also wenn überhaupt wenn überhaupt irgendwelche youtube videos
aber meistens gar nichts
Meistens gibt es es gibt eine ordnung das linsen gericht ja das ist da in diese ecke
Meistens gar nichts ich habe auch keine kopfhörer oder sonst was meistens auf und auch keine in irs und was ich laufe einfach nur
Durch den wald oder durch das über die felder oder hügel wie auch immer ganz ohne was weil ganz im ernst ich sitze den ganzen
Tag vom rechner ich habe fast den ganzen tag in headseit auf kopfhörer auf
Ich finde das eigentlich mal ganz entspannt einfach nix auf den ohren zu haben nix drumherum
und
Ja man braucht keine zehn stunden forrest noises wenn man einfach selbst durch den forrest forrest läuft
Aber gucken wir uns mal weiter das video an das halte ich jeden tag von der küche aus arbeit für meine arbeit reicht das zwar völlig aus
Aber was meinst du könntest du so für ein paar wochen arbeiten nein auf gar keinen fall chat wie sieht es bei euch aus
Ich könnte auf gar keinen fall so also nicht nur zwei wochen ich könnte nicht einen tag so arbeiten
Also erstens was mir mega fehlen würde ist ein stuhl mit
Ja
Und ich könnte nicht mit touchpad und tastatur den ganzen tag arbeiten da würde ich durchdrehen
Performance technisch ist das setup wahrscheinlich vollkommen in ordnung
Das würde ich aber nicht aushalten ich brauche meine ordentliche ich brauche meine mechanische ordentliche full-size
tastatur eine gescheite maus
Naja das wichtigste ist sowieso dass ich alles um mich herum habe und ich kann nicht alles um mich herum
Ich kann nicht alles um mich herum haben und ich kann nicht alles um mich herum haben
Naja das wichtigste ist sowieso dass ich alles um mich herum habe sobald die arbeit losgeht also mache ich mir einen kaffee und das
Wasser darf auch ich da muss ich sagen gerade im homeoffice also hier das haus hat ja
erdgeschoss erster stock dachgeschoss
Und ich bin ich bin im ersten stock
Und ich habe zwar eine kleine küche hier oben aber die ein die hauptküche ist unten im erdgeschoss
Und ich mache das eigentlich ganz gerne dass ich mir immer mal neuen tee oder wasser oder irgendwas unten aus der küche hol
Weil dann läuft man zwischendurch ein paar mal am tag die treppe hoch und runter das bringt auch schon ein bisschen was
Anstatt den ganzen tag nur in schlechter haltung vom rechner zu sitzen und den monitor zu gucken
Nicht dass man noch vierkäge augen kriegt wie das meine oma immer prophezeit hat
Also mache ich mir einen kaffee und das wasser darf auch nicht fehlen
Hat er wirklich seine kamera gerade ins glas geschmissen um diesen schrott aufzunehmen
Es geht also mache ich mir einen kaffee und das wasser darf auch nicht fehlen
Bester winkel das wollte ich schon unbedingt mal sehen franz franz ist ein dackel
Bester name für den dackel überhaupt
Franz
In den letzten wochen
Franz hat set haben wir an der neuen untertitel und audiospur funktion gearbeitet
Ach ja falls du neu hier bist ich arbeite bei dem tv streaming an die weibung weibung nicht nicht satu ich habe es verwechselt weibu
Die sprache des tons ändern und untertitel gibt es auch alle zwei wochen stellen wir der ganzen firma die neuen funktionen vor heute
Bin ich dran das feature vorzustellen weshalb ich die apps für die präsentation
Vorbereiten muss bin mal gespannt was meine kollegen dazu sagen
Gutenmorgen ios hat an den untertiteln für mobile gearbeitet wenn wir jetzt untertitel haben wollen dann klicken wir hier einfach einmal in das
Bild rein wir bekommen diese player controls und wir haben jetzt hier neuen wieso braucht man weibu tv
Vielleicht leute die kein fernseh daheim haben also kein kein fernsehanschluss kein kabelanschluss wollte ich damit sagen oder auch kein
Wie heißt das andere magenta hast du nicht gesehen denkt also die leute die fernsehprogramm gucken wollen ohne halt einen anderen
Anschlussmöglichkeit dafür zu haben warum nicht ist doch eigentlich ganz sinnig für mich persönlich wäre es ehrlich gesagt auch nix weil ich konsumiere so gut wie
Kein fernsehprogramm und wenn ich fernsehprogramm konsumiere dann vielleicht bei ihnen eine sportübertragung oder so ich habe beispielsweise dieses jahr
paar tour de france haben nebenbei geguckt
Am liebsten gucke ich eigentlich in eurosport aber leider hat eurosport nur noch
Bezahl paywall also habe ich mir die die bilder übers erste angeguckt also wenn schon das kann man sich ja auch live stream im internet
angucken also insofern
Wenn ich überhaupt mal fernseh irgendwas gucke dann ist es
Ehe nur irgendein freie zugängliches programm also ich bräuchte es nicht aber ich kann es durchaus verstehen dass das leute benutzen hast ja ein video recorder
integriert
Leider alles halt komplett cloud basierten kriegst die sachen wahrscheinlich auch nie wieder raus aber ich verstehe es schon so ist auch eigentlich ganz praktisch
Für untertitel und audio tracks und jetzt sollten gleich die untertitel angehen
Die gleiche funktion haben wir natürlich auch auf ipad
Ich fände das übrigens ein richtig cooles konzept
Das problem ist ich würde prinzipiell auch mal gern so ein video machen
Es dumme ist ich will erstens nicht liegen wo ich arbeite und das zweite ist was soll ich filmen
Ich kann mich nicht filmen weil liegt und ich kann meinen bildschirm nicht filmen weil liegt das ich kann so ein video nicht machen
Funktioniert bei mir einfach nicht
Top idee kurz zeigen wie das auf ipad aussieht also die funktionalität ist exakt die gleiche
Wir haben jetzt halt hier unten haben wir dann einfach einen button
Und wenn ich drauf klicke dann öffnet sich der screen so
Okay die präsentation lief sehr gut wie immer gab es ein paar frage
Wahrscheinlich war das so eine präsentation wo alle nur
Pflichtmäßig da sind und alles abnicken also haben wir ja auch so nach dem motto hier weekly dingsbungs präsentation
Oh alter überhaupt kein bock drauf okay wenn einer was vorstellt nick einfach stellt keine fragen dann ist man möglichst schnell wieder raus
so typische weekly meetings halt
Nicht zu überraschen das wurdest du eigentlich schon mal in der öffentlichkeit erkannt wegen stimme und so ja mehrfach schon
Also offensichtlich das war natürlich auf der gamescom
Wie lange geht eigentlich ein daily scrum also ich habe ich habe ein team daily und ich habe ein richtig echtes daily scrum
Das richtig echte daily scrum geht moment ich kann es euch sagen ich gucke mal kurz ich glaube eine viertel stunde
Pass mal auf ich gucke ich gucke mal guck mal kurz
Teams sie wurden den teams abgemeldet melden sie sich neu an alter nervt jetzt nicht
Ist übrigens auch lustig wenn ich die meldung bekomme sie wurden von teams abgemeldet und ich habe ein team daily
Bekommen sie wurden von teams abgemeldet muss ich teams schließen und wieder öffnen melden sich automatisch an muss gar kein passwort eintippen
So kalender also daily scrum
Daily projekts scrum 9.30 bis 9.45 15 minuten danach habe ich
Infrastruktur daily 10 bis 10.15 also 2 mal 15 minuten
Danach habe ich noch jede menge andere gemiete gemiete sachen aber die gehen länger und dienstag 1 august wird wieder ganz schrecklich
Pass mal auf leute ich lese euch mal vor was dienstag abgeht sprint review 9.30 bis 11 uhr
Produkt produkt teams scrum 9.30 bis 9.45 ihr entdeckt vielleicht dass sich das überschneidet aber ok
Infrastruktur daily 10 bis 10.15 sprint retrospektive 11 bis 12.30 sprint planung 14.30 bis 16.30
Heißt im endeffekt am dienstag mache ich nichts 0, gar nichts außer mieten den ganzen tag von morgens bis mittags
Und das witzige ist mittwochs morgens haben wir dann wieder daily und dann fragen sie dann und gab es schon progress
Dann denke ich mir so ok dienstag ist der erste tag die wort der woche wo ich da bin ich habe den ganzen dienstag von morgens bis mittags gemietet
Und jetzt ist es mittwoch 9.30 wann soll ich progress gemacht haben mittwochs morgens um 7 von bis 9.30 oder
Bei sprint reden die dann auf zweimal geschwindigkeit sollte ich vielleicht mal vorschlagen
Es ist dann ein ein was schon wieder Sekunde mikrofon knackt test test test test ich bewege mich mal gucken ob irgendwas locker ist
Mikrofon knackt test test test test ich bewege mich mal gucken ob irgendwas locker ist da knackt nichts war gerade ganz kurz
Ja das kann sein ich bin gerade bin gerade wild rumgefahren mit meinem stuhl vom handy vom vom tisch neben dran zum handy
Vielleicht habe ich irgendwas an der verlängerung gewackelt ja das das kann sein sagt das doch deinem vorgesetzten der weiß das
Was soll der denn da machen das ist halt in dem projekt ist das halt so dass wir alle 14 tage einmal ganz nach mieten
Bist du eigentlich zufrieden mit deiner neuen arbeit stellen ja zum größten teil schon also ich finde das war eine wirklich gute entscheidung
Da dass das zu machen also erstens bin ich muss ich mich nicht mehr mit dem schritt auseinandersetzen beim letzten arbeitgeber und außerdem
Finde ich die kombination aus so den sachen die man im vorfeld wusste gute homeoffice regel ordentlich kohle finde ich gut beim neuen und die arbeitsatmosphäre
Und die leute sind auch wirklich sehr nice und auch das projekt in dem ich bin ist sehr nice kann hauptsächlich cloud geschichten machen worauf ich eh bock habe
Und kann mir auch neue sachen angucken ausprobieren und einführen also eigentlich eine coole geschichte so vielleicht erzähle ich euch auch mal in einem video was ich genau mache
Wie beim letzten job ja auch schon muss ich mal aufschreiben aber es gibt natürlich auch ein paar sachen die ich nicht so schön finde zum beispiel dass das alles äußerst bürokratisch und restriktiv ist
Also ich habe ja gesagt ich kann mir neue dinge angucken und einführen aber das ist halt ein riesenakt ja zum beispiel möchte ich das hier einführen bei uns zwar das ding
Den cloud sql proxy operator das ist quasi so ein background service für kubernetes haben übrigens letztens auch im stream zusammen uns angeguckt
So ein background service für kubernetes der datenbank ganz kurz gesagt ist das anwendung des einfacher macht für anwendungen auf datenbanken zuzugreifen ja das trifft das trifft glaube ich ganz gut
Und ich musste jetzt zwei tagen warten auf firewall freischaltung da ich es überhaupt ausprobieren konnte und dann hat schon irgendjemand anderes gesagt ja aber in produktion verwenden dürfen wir das ohne gültiges terraform modul nicht
Das ist ein kubernetes operator machst du kubectl apply-f dann machst du es admin technisch einmal und gut ist dann brauchst du kein terraform file für was hat das mit terraform zu tun ja aber irgendjemand hat entschieden es braucht ein terraform modul dafür
Also die sind da sehr geplagt durch alte prozesse die noch aus reiner offline on prem zeit kommen ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das sich ja also es hat sich schon ein bisschen aufgeweicht aber ich glaube das muss sich noch ein bisschen mehr aufweichen
Aber ansonsten finde ich es gut meine probezeit ist übrigens auch bald um ich habe im ersten vierten angefangen das heißt in zwei monaten ist meine probezeit rum und ich hatte schon mein erstes zwischengespräch und am ende der probezeit habe ich noch eins
Zwischengespräch lief eigentlich so ich habe mir extra jede menge zeug aufgeschrieben und das war viel zu schnell vorbei ich konnte gar nicht alles loswerden also die finden es toll ich finde es auch gut also wir sind beide seiten sind richtig richtig zufrieden damit freut mich auch also man muss ja sagen ich habe mich da übelst übelst gelobt ja auch wie das wie gut das schon klappt und wie gut das hier im team schon funktioniert
Also hat mich dann auch gefreut ja also wirklich wirklich nice ja
Max hast du nun linux oder oder noch windows beides mein notebook ist das offizielle notebook von der firma das hat nur windows
Ich habe aber eine linux vm auf der ich root bin ins internet kann und alles mögliche machen kann wo ich mich austoben kann das heißt ich benutze mein windows eigentlich hauptsächlich nur für fullscreen terminal
Wie gut sind jetzt deine kuberneteskenntnisse geworden ich würde sagen noch besser als am anfang ja wenn man das täglich benutzt davor ist jetzt ja nicht so dass ich täglich an kubernetes rumgeschraubt habe ich habe mal die ein oder anderen sachen damit gemacht und habe da auch mal mich längere zeit am stück mit beschäftigt aber nicht täglich seitdem ich mich täglich damit beschäftige sind vor allem die hubctl kommandos mir mehr in fleisch und blut übergegangen wie man wie man ein bisschen kompliziertere sachen macht ja zum beispiel
Ihr habt einen port in dem zwei container laufen und ihr wollt euch logs anzeigen lassen wie zeigt ihr euch die logs von von ja dem zweiten container quasi an da muss man dann noch minus c und den namen hinten angeben das weiß ich aus dem kopf hätte ich das früher nicht gewusst mittlerweile weiß ich aus dem kopf
Ich muss immer kritisieren wenn das leute so aussprechen ist wir haben einige leute die es kubectl nennen und ich weiß beim besten will nicht warum es ist doch offensichtlich dass es kube steht für kubernetes und ctl steht für control so wie systemctl es heißt ja auch nicht systemctl bei mir kacken meine ingress engine x ports permanent beim loadtest ab
Ja da würde ich mal sagen hast du deine ressourcen ein bisschen zu gering eingestellt du kannst auch mal gucken ob du die dinger nicht skalieren kannst also kannst ja die sachen sowohl horizontal als auch vertikal skalieren jetzt mal spaß beiseite mit diagonal skalieren es gibt wobei ich sagen muss den vertical scaler habe ich in kubernetes nie ausprobiert du kannst ja auch neue ports erstellen lassen mit mehrere also wo die ressourcen limits höher sind automatisch
Also wenn deine readiness und liveness probes abkacken dann höchstwahrscheinlich weil du nicht genug ressourcen beantragt hast für deinen port 150 alter das dürfte aber eines der heftigsten quasi ingress dinger sein 150 scheint ein ordentlicher cluster zu sein oder wenn du 150 ingress ports hast krasser scheiße nicht ohne
Kannst du eine plattform empfehlen auf der man docker und ähnliches lernen kann docker docker ist einfach linux vm bei dir lokal localhost genau docker lernst du am besten lokal du kannst alles lokal lernen in dieser richtung kannst containerisierung mit docker du kannst image bilden und so kannst alles lokal machen brauchst du brauchst du nichts für wenn es dann in richtung kubernetes geht dann kannst du dir minikube angucken für lokalen cluster oder du holst dir eine hetzer vm
Wobei ich das persönlich eigentlich nicht so geil finde ich finde eine komplette manage plattform in dem fall besser da kannst du digital ausnehmen was sie in den mini cluster das ist dann auch nicht so teuer
So ok schauen wir uns das Video an wo sind wir stehen geblieben das IOS Team hat Untertitel implementiert
Wie immer gab es ein paar Fragen aber nichts überraschendes diese Präsentation ist bei uns immer der letzte Schritt bevor eine neue Funktion für die Kunden ausgerollt wird natürlich machen wir das nicht bei jeder Kleinigkeit aber so eine nützliche Funktion wie Untertitel und Audiospuren sind besonders für Leute mit Hör- und Sehschwächen sinnvoll
Das Ende einer Aufgabe ist
Äh was haben wir hier ist das Flutter?
Ne was ist denn das?
Was ist denn das?
Was ist das Chat?
Ähm ist das Swift?
Ist das Swift?
Swift? Ja?
Ah ja man sieht es an dem Icon hier guck mal das ist das Swift Logo
Oder ist das das Swift Logo?
Swift Logo
Ja das ist das Swift Logo
Okay Swift IOS
Finde ich ein guter Ansatz
Das die richtig echte
Native Apps bauen
Da kannst du dir auch sicher sein das die am besten funktionieren
Beziehungsweise am besten
Die am besten auf der jeweiligen Plattform anfühlen
Und ich weiß nicht wie gut das mit
Audio Video mit Flutter und so schon funktioniert
Würde sagen prinzipiell ja
Aber sicherlich ganz gut
Aber ich denke es ist eine gute Wahl
Für so eine Multimedia heavy Anwendung
Einfach für die zwei
Verschiedenen
Für die zwei verbreiteten
Mobile Systeme eine Native App zu bauen
Okay
Aber immer der Beginn der nächsten
Deshalb springen wir doch direkt mal in die Programmierung rein
Ein andauerndes Thema ist bei uns
Das Redesign der App
Einfach damit Funktionen besser verstanden werden
Und alles hübscher und moderner wird
Der nächste Bereich sind unsere Aufnahmen
Denn man kann Sendungen von der App
Aufnehmen lassen und sie zu einem
Späteren Zeitpunkt ansehen
Dabei bekomme ich ein Design vorgegeben
Und wie immer programmiere ich das so
Eins zu eins so in unserer App
Also dabei könnte ich mich nicht konzentrieren
Hat jeder unterschiedlichen Geschmack
Also ich höre mir auch ganz gerne irgendwelche
Chill-Streams, Lofi-Streams
Sonst was an
Aber das ist mir irgendwie zu
Einschneidend
Ich hab mir vor ein paar Monaten ein
iPad gekauft und jetzt mal ganz ehrlich
Obwohl ich das eigentlich für die
Softwareentwicklung an sich nicht brauche
Bin ich wirklich super happy damit
Denn ich mach da viel Skizzen
Planung und so weiter
Und wenn ich es gerade mal nicht aktiv benutze
Dann benutze ich es
Einfach als externen Zweitmonitor
Und das ist eigentlich echt krass wie gut es eigentlich
Funktioniert weil ich hab hier halt meine
AI oder was auch immer
Ich hab aber trotzdem keinen Bock drauf auf die Kombination
Aus nur Laptop und iPad
Ich weiß nicht
Ich brauch einen gescheiten Bildschirm
Am besten zwei gescheite Bildschirme
Ordentliche Tastatur, ordentliche Maus
Sonst dreh ich ab bei
Und hier solche Dinge wie Spotify
Der ist im Urlaub
Ich geh mal davon aus
Da hat er daheim schon ein gescheites Setup
Der ist doch im Urlaub
Der hat doch letztens im letzten Video erzählt
Dass er irgendwie drei Monate
Da irgendwie Remote
Dings hat in Spanien
Slack oder
Mein ganz normales Terminal
Also das ist echt praktisch wie gut es funktioniert
Und das ruckelt halt auch überhaupt nicht
Ich habe allerdings sowieso
Ein eigenständiges Video geplant
Wie ich mein iPad als Softwareentwickler
Benutze, falls ich bestimmte
Punkte abdecken soll
Dann schreibt sie auf jeden Fall unten in die Kommentare
Dann werde ich das mit in das Video
Einbauen
Dafür gibt es da immer gesundes und gut aussehendes Essen
In Spanien
Fragezeichen Punkt ist wahrscheinlich
In Zwift auch so
Moment
Kann Self jemals null sein
In Zwift
Das ergibt doch gar keinen Sinn
Wie sollte Self jemals null sein
Aber vielleicht ist das in Zwift
Auch eine andere Syntax für andere
Dinger
Ja würde ich vermuten
Ganz chill, der macht das richtig
Der Bauer gerade hat ein neues Video
Aus der Serverhalle gepostet
Was hat er
Der Auer
Dieses geheime Rechenzentrum mit über
25.000 Servern steht
Bei 1&1
Das ist 1&1 oder
Ich glaub schon
Paper für dich erstellt, die du wie immer kostenlos
Auf meiner Webseite herunterladen kannst
Link findest du unten
Warum interessiert dich das
Sollen machen was sie wollen
Die an erster Stelle steht
Und etwas größer ist
Das heißt in der Logik muss ich erstmal die erste Aufnahme
Darkseid ich hab übrigens auch was überlegt
Ich zeig dir beim nächsten Stream mal
Bin mir noch nicht sicher in welchem
Wie das mit Essing Await genau funktioniert
Da machen wir ein Essing Await Stream
Ausfiltern die man sich schon ansehen kann
Denn es gibt natürlich auch Aufnahmen die in der Zukunft liegen
Und diese rausgefilterte Aufnahmen
Kann denn es gibt natürlich auch Aufnahmen
Die in der Zukunft liegen
Diese rausgefilterte Aufnahme zeige ich dann ganz oben an
In der restlichen Liste soll diese Aufnahme
Dann natürlich nicht mehr angezeigt werden
Irgendwo ist noch der Wurm drin
Weshalb ich ChatGPT mal frage
Wo der Fehler liegt
Ah der Fehler lag an
Es ist jetzt nicht mehr
Stack Overflow Driven Programming
Es ist jetzt ChatGPT Driven Programming
Für solche Sachen ist ChatGPT
Sehr hilfreich, stimmt schon
Ich hab ChatGPT auch letztens
Nach einem Logikfehler
In einem Sensible Playbook gefragt
Da musst du halt immer aufpassen
Dass du nicht zu viele
Interne rein
Copy Pastest
In einer komplett anderen Stelle
Denn die Aufnahme die ich ganz oben anzeigen möchte
Hatte ich zwar korrekt rausgefiltert
Aber in der Benutzeroberfläche
Naja Darkzone du musst schon ein bisschen überlegen
Was du dahin schickst
Nicht verwendet
Also auf dem iPhone sieht es schon mal ganz gut aus
Jetzt muss ich noch ein paar Änderungen
Am iPad machen
Das ist ja offensichtlich, denn auf dem iPad haben wir natürlich
Viel mehr Platz als auf dem iPhone
Das bedeutet auf dem iPad wollen wir nicht nur
Die Liste an sich anzeigen
Sondern noch so eine Seitenleiste
Mit einbauen, damit wir Filter
Und Sortierungsmöglichkeiten direkt
Auf einem Screen haben
Bevor ich diese Seitenleiste aber programmiere
Werde ich erstmal die Liste fertig machen
Und dann im Anschluss noch die Optimierung
Für das iPad übernehmen
Hackermann-Modus aktiviert
Seht ihr mal da
Was ist denn da eigentlich los
Warum ist denn ein Softwareentwickler den ganzen Tag am Software entwickeln
Wenn man sich die anderen Videos anguckt
In dieser Richtung
Da entwickeln die aber nicht den ganzen Tag Software
Da gehen die jetzt erstmal eine Runde noch
Ins Fitnessstudio mit ihren Kollegen
Oder so komische Dinger
Oder lassen sich mit dem betriebseigenen Bus
Zur Kantine fahren und dann
Gehen sie zusammen abends noch
Ins Fitnessstudio
Also
Das ist deutlich realistischer
Hier an der Realität dran
Franz muss aufs Klo
Multi-Cursor
Wir haben nun halb 6 und für heute habe ich wirklich genug
Weggeschafft bekommen
Man muss ja schließlich auch das gute Wetter genießen
Da gibt es jetzt erstmal ein Eis
Und wir gehen in den Fluss schwimmen
Da hätte ich ja Schiss, dass es nicht tief genug ist
Das ist so ein Ding
Das könntest du in Deutschland halt einfach nicht machen
Ja
So nach dem Motto
Oh ja da ist ein Fluss, da schwimmen wir mal
Und springen von der Brücke drüben rein
Da ist hier sofort die Polizei am Start
Für heute Abend sind wir zum Essen in der Stadt verabredet
Da gibt es eine richtig geile Pizzeria
Ich hoffe es ist keine Trost Musik
Ich wollte die Pizza eigentlich komplett zeigen
Hab aber einfach drauf los gegessen
Damit gute Nacht
Und bis zum nächsten Mal
Pizza mit Messer und Gabel essen
Macht man das in Spanien so?
Ich dachte es wird immer
Direkt am Stück reingefuttert
Das war doch mal ein recht realistischer Tag
Er hat den ganzen Tag als Softwareentwickler
Mehr oder weniger Software entwickelt
Und ein bisschen gemietet
Er entdeckt sich das ganz gut mit meinem Tag
Nur dass ich halt nicht Software entwickle
Hauptberuflich den ganzen Tag
Aber es wird gemietet
Und halt das gemacht
Wofür man da ist letztendlich
Hi Max ich hab ziemlich die gleiche
Docker Compose Traffic Config wie du
Ja ich benutze das bloß gar nicht mehr
Wo hast du denn meine Config her?
Du meinst das aus dem Stream
Was ich mal gezeigt hab
Der hat ja schon vor einer Weile Videos gemacht
Ja die hab ich gesehen
Ich finde da gibt es bessere Plattformen als in Raspberry Pi
Weil man PC Express braucht
Ich finde das sehr komisch dass die überlegen wie die App aussieht
Ja deswegen sieht die App wahrscheinlich auch
Halbwegs brauchbar aus
Wenn die Leute einfach nur wild drauf loswurschteln
Dann kommen halt manche Crap Apps raus
Aber nachdem
Und das ist verständlich in dem Fall ja auch
Nachdem ein nicht unerheblicher Teil ihrer User
Mich würde nicht wundern
Wenn über 50 oder wenn nicht sogar über 60
70 Prozent
Der Leute die App
Generell ihre User hauptsächlich
Auf Mobile unterwegs sind
Oder sagen wir mal auf Geräten mit Android
Oder IOS sei es jetzt
iPad, Android TV, Android
Ist es natürlich sehr sinnvoll da
Bisschen
FiFad reinzustecken
ABAP UI5 das hört sich sehr nach
SAP an oder?
Da hätte ich ja gar keinen Bock drauf
Kann ich Subdomains damit auch auf
Andere IPs Proxien? Klar
Das ist ja der Sinn von einem
Reverse Proxy
Du sagst
Tja immer diese
Anfrage
Ich lausche auf Port 8000
Und intern leite ich das weiter
Dahin auf Port sowieso
Die Sachen mit
Mit den unterschiedlichen Domains
Das liegt ja
An deiner quasi V-Host
Konfig
Wo das dann hingeht
Dein Reverse Proxy
Tauscht an Port keine Ahnung
8080, 8000, 8443
Was auch immer
Und die Anfragen die da reinkommen
Die werden dann weiter geproxied
Auf irgendwas anderes intern
Das geht das ist überhaupt kein Ding
Ich weiß aber gar nicht mehr genau
Was ich dort überhaupt gemacht habe
Mit Traffic im Stream
Ich benutze das selbst nicht mehr
Ich weiß was du meinst
Du willst irgendwelche Traffic Labels setzen
Und sowas ganz ehrlich
Das ist die einzige Kombination die ich kenne
Das einzige Gute
Wie man Traffic verwenden kann ist
Entweder in der Kombination
Docker Compose und automatisches
Importieren von den Labels
Und sowas
Oder im Kubernetes Umfeld als Ingress
Und dann halt auch zum größten Teil
Über Labels automatisch konfiguriert
Wobei ich in allen diesen Fällen
Tatsächlich Nginx bevorzuge
Mittlerweile oder
Wenn es wirklich simpel sein muss
Wenn man direkte Let's Encrypt Unterstützung braucht
Dann Kadi
Tatsächlich mache ich jetzt
Nginx Proxy Manager
Benutze ich intern
Mittlerweile
Wir hatten auch ziemlich große Sicherheitsprobleme vor einem Jahr
Also
Muss man gucken dass man updatet
Wobei für interne Sachen
Macht es keinen großen Unterschied
Ist Traffic der Proxy von Kubernetes?
Nee
Traffic schreibt man übrigens so
Das ist
Ein extra
Webserver
HTTP Reverse Proxy
Load Balancer
Und ich finde die haben es bei der Version 2
Komplett verkackt mit den Configs
Niemand versteht wie Traffic Configs richtig aussehen müssen
Das ist
Alles in einem
Der offizielle
Kubernetes Proxy
Ist der hier
Das ist der
Offizieller wird das nicht
Ja du kannst mit Traffic
Im Prinzip auch das machen was Nginx kann
Nginx würde ich sagen
Kann unter dem Strich sogar noch ein Ticken mehr
Echt
Mein Mikrofon ist am Abkacken
Warum
Was ist das denn
Ich entwirre mal
Mein
Ich entwirre mal kurz
Mein Headset Kabel
Müssen wir mal schauen
Mal kurz ein bisschen Google an
Weil die letzten Streams
Gab es doch keine Probleme
Ja ich entwirre mal das Kabel
Es kann durchaus sein dass es ein bisschen Probleme hat
So
Jetzt habe ich das Kabel wieder eingesteckt
Jetzt hoffe ich das alles geht
Bluetooth ne geht
Ja also das ist der offizielle Nginx
Der offizielle Ingress von Kubernetes
Offizieller wird das nicht
Man darf sich übrigens
Nicht verwirren lassen
Ne das habe ich nicht mitbekommen
Man darf sich übrigens nicht verwirren lassen
Es gibt nämlich
Einen Ingress Nginx Controller
Und es gibt einen Nginx
Ingress Controller
Und wer von euch würde jetzt spontan denken
Dass es das gleiche Produkt ist
Aber nein der liegt falsch
Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Sachen
Wo wir wieder bei toller Benahmung in der Cloud Native
Kubernetes Welt sind
Ingress Nginx ist der offizielle
Ingress Controller von Kubernetes der auf Nginx
basiert
What
Was ist das denn
Okay Leute wir testen jetzt mal was
Wir hatten das letzte Mal ja Probleme
Wenn ich meinen Browser reloadet habe
Browser reload
Ja Youtube
Schaust du dir den Clip
Selbst an
Hast du den geknackt
Browser
Nginx Controller und es gibt einen
Nginx Ingress Controller
Ich habe es gehört
Und es gibt einen
Windows
Ich schiebe es mal auf Windows
Nginx Ingress Controller
Und wer von euch würde jetzt spontan denken
Dass es das gleiche Produkt ist
Macht meine VM im Hintergrund
Irgendwelche Probleme
Guck mal rein was hier gerade
Was hier gerade passiert
Ja auf jetzt
Ehrlich gesagt passiert auf einem Rechner nichts
Nichts
Was hat denn der Chrome hier für
Der macht ja auch nicht wirklich was
Keine Ahnung
Weiß nicht
Keine Ahnung was das für Schmerzen hat
Ja aber soviel zu dieser Nginx Ingress Geschichte
Es gibt zwei verschiedene
Das ist der offizielle und der
Nginx Ingress ist der vom
Nginx Projekt die auch einen anbieten
Aber das hier ist der verbreitete
Echt keine Ahnung was das für Schmerzen hat
Ihr könnt
Es ist nicht mal als hätte ich irgendwas gemacht
Ich starte mal neu
Nächstes mal ist es wahrscheinlich wieder weg
Windows Logik muss man nicht verstehen
Lass uns mal gucken
Passiert jetzt irgendwas
Ich wackele mal am USB Kabel hier
Ist eigentlich auch alles okay
Oh am USB Kabel
USB Kabel wackeln
Ne ne alles gut
Dann weiß ich es nicht was es für Schmerzen hat
Keine Ahnung
Muss neu starten
Das kann es ja nicht sein
Aber davon abgesehen ich muss jetzt eh was essen
Ich hab Hunger Leute ich geh jetzt was futtern
Und wir sehen uns entweder nachher
Oder morgen
Bis denn machts gut
CU